Maybe a little.
Oops.
A little bit, yeah.
I am away from Made Cafe because I am getting ready for
Ofcourse.
yippee yippee oh why though am i so laggy that's fine oh
chat frozen oh it does even say chat disconnected
refresh we good everything's fine hello everybody hello
hello hello a little lag is a treat hopefully hopefully it's
not too distracting hopefully it's not too distracting no
just finished packing exciting well of course even if i have
a convention this weekend i was like well i'm free today so
why not stream i thought the title said hotline miami but
the thumbnail not even a little bit looks like a dub with
the mouth sink I'm sorry I don't know why it lags I don't
know why it lags when I'm away it also might just be my
travel computer maybe it's not as beefy as I wish it could
be adds to the charm hopefully it's not too distracting X
Xbox mic wait does it does it sound bad does it sound bad
wait it shouldn't be xbox it should be nice mic it's crunchy
mic is fine huh you sound closer well i do have to get a
little close to my mic because otherwise you won't be able
to hear me i think
But it is a little like...
It is kind of like in my face a little bit.
One guide.
Actually, slightly crunchy around the edges.
I even tested it before stream.
I even tested it and I was like, oh.
Okay, this sounds good.
Hmm.
Weird.
Pizza is crunchy.
an oven baked pizza no sorry i mean they're all oven baked a
fire the fire ones you know what i'm talking about we have
some liars and chat loki yeah flame baked pizza
that's me that's me simulating wanting pizza in my mouth
waiting for pizza Luckily I just ate though So I'm not I'm
not so What's the word?
So starved
Manifesting pizza I hope I can get it this weekend though
Virtual pizza for the ghost There might be a blaze pizza
near off guy What's that?
Blazer pizza hungry no not hungry at all hope san jose has
good pizza me too hi me though it is i x dude awesome hello
x dude awesome thanks for being here again
i like blaze is it like my favorite pizza place is mod pizza
but i feel like sometimes mod pizza depends on who's working
you know what i mean you know when you like and that's the
most frustrating part is going to a restaurant and the
quality depending on the good like the person that like
makes it you know what i mean because otherwise it's so my
favorite is a local place i tried a local place uh not too
long ago actually and it was pretty good But holy cow, was
it expensive?
So I was like, maybe I'll get this like twice a year.
It's crazy.
Consistency matters.
I agree.
It's a minor gamble.
But for pizza, I feel like, okay, I like a more toasted
pizza, right?
So if it's too doughy, I'm like, ugh, it's ruined.
I don't, I don't make the rules.
It's just the truth.
if my pizza is too doughy i'm like no i i can't have it it's
yeah i like it crispy i like it crispy this is just how it
works exactly
gummy pizza i don't want that like a thin crust but i don't
want a thin crust otherwise i would order it that way but
i'm pretty sure mod like all other pizzas are kind of
playthrough sin crust.
Just put it in the oven.
But if I get the pizza, that means I'm hungry now.
And sometimes I eat it there.
There's a sensible and healthy portion crew at my local
Culver's.
And I told the window lady, ma'am, I need you to try and end
me with Reese's Cubs.
Not the reasonable portion, people.
But sometimes I appreciate that.
Actually, I did.
Hold on.
I'm gonna fix my micro click I did end up getting ice cream
after my outfit debut and usually when I go there's one girl
that like loads me up and I was like I'm like oh yeah I'm
getting like so much that I have to I have to like stick it
in my freezer I can't finish it even though I get the
smallest size but this time the girl the girl the girl that
was working did not give me so much and i was like i was
like okay well actually this is probably good i don't need
so much i don't need so much ice cream probably oh she likes
you
Maybe.
But maybe, I don't know.
I also don't want to become a regular.
A regular at...
I think a regular at an ice cream store is kind of
embarrassing.
This is like...
No, I think she's just a good worker, honestly.
But...
I don't want to be a regular at an ice cream store.
Bad!
What?
No, why?
Because it's ice cream.
That would mean I eat so much ice cream that they would
remember me.
Ice cream regulars are the coolest actually.
But
can't a girl be known for her whimsy?
It's better than a bar.
Okay, wait.
Maybe you're on to something there.
Hello, is this 444310 maid?
I'd like to report that the minto is super cute and makes my
heart beat that doesn't normally fast.
Should I be worried?
sounds like your minto is um is is doing your proper job
spooking you making you hold on
going to order a whole chicago deep dish at 800 calories a
slice i was looking at a pancake place the other day and i
was like berry pancakes and then i saw like a cinnamon
pancake it was like a cinnamon cinnamon roll pancake and i
was like mmm cinnamon roll pancakes i think the berry
pancakes were like i don't remember but the cinnamon roll
pancakes were over a thousand calories one zero zero zero
four digit calories worth of pancakes alone.
Hell yeah.
Let me give you my birthday today.
Ask for your permission to marry Lilac and you.
Thanks for all the hard work this year and all the joy
you've given me.
Can't wait for off, Kai.
Mr. Phantom Happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
I don't know.
You have to ask Lilac.
You can't ask me.
I'm in the airport waiting because my flight's been delayed
by two and a half hours.
Wish me luck, please.
Oh my gosh, Death Pigeon.
Good luck, good luck, good luck, good luck.
It could be worse.
It could be cancelled, but it's not, you know?
I've been approved to drive after my brain surgery.
Fools.
Congrats on being
a- in a bit i get to catch stream because i'm staying up
late to head to germany for a final fantasy event love the
cute new look of me thanks brand thank you make sure you get
some sleep though hold on my chat is lagging okay there we
go guys i just broke a nail
man freak my chungus afterlife i just broke a nail Freak my
chungus afterlife
The boo made me jump And drop my croissant You almost made
me drop my croissant
Chungus Today we're playing home safety hotline
I've never played this before So I'm very excited I only
know like a teeny tiny bit about it So that's a shirt quilt
right there maybe i should write that on one of the shirts
so it's kind of funny because i was like to steiner i was
like steiner my manager i was like can i like draw some
t-shirts for off kai and he was like sure and i was like i
just want to see people if if you know if anyone buys them
but i just want to see people wearing shirts that i draw He
was like, okay.
And then it didn't ask me again.
And then I got really busy with the outfit and I forgot
about it.
And then they put up the merch catalog.
And I was like, oh.
I haven't done those yet.
Can you guys go get me some shirts?
You're upstream.
Wow.
Helmeto from the plane.
Delta Wi-Fi.
Do you have a preference?
what dinner I should have for you to possess once I land.
In and out!
So yeah, after this I will be drawing some shirts.
I will be drawing some shirts today, tonight, and tomorrow.
I love this game.
Hot dog!
It's made by the same people as Forbidden Solitaire.
I know!
I'm so excited.
I'm flying in the day of the day.
the concert can you bless me with good luck so so I don't
get delayed and miss it oh my gosh Kotaku that's so scary
bliss bliss I hope I can get one I'm letting you know right
now they are so there's like okay there's since I am
literally I'm drawing each one with like pen you know it's
it is it is they are they I can only do so many right so um
there will there will be uh I I I wanted to do more um there
will only be 10 of them honestly I didn't think it was
actually gonna happen i kind of proposed it as a joke and
then i was like well this is this this is fine
10 each day no i don't have time to draw 10 each day
coincidentally i'm also drawing a shirt although not with 10
i hope yours goes much more productively than mine that's so
exciting yeah they're all gonna be unique because i'm
drawing them by hand they're all look it's it's It's me
hovering over my desk.
And...
I bet they'll sell out before the hall even opens.
I'm going to be part of the problem.
No!
I will tell them not to do that.
It's still over.
No!
Again, I didn't realize.
I didn't realize.
Hello, home safety hotline.
There's this silvering silver.
What?
Wait, here?
in green-haired ghost mode on my computer screen she keeps
buying metal gear solid off of steam i'm up to 50 copies of
snake eater what do i do keep going keep going
but yeah good luck getting the other the nine other shirts
i've
like i said I couldn't propose that as a joke and it
happened for real But I will try and make some very cute
shirts for those who get them Yeah, don't, don't, don't You
know, again, I don't want people to be like Oh man, I
couldn't get one I don't even feel like they're overpriced
Still was, I saw the price and I was like I was like, dang
But I'm like drawing it with Sharpie Like it shouldn't be
that much But I have some ideas, but now I want to write
Freak My Chungus Afterlife on it.
I'll write...
Hey, Minto, it's my birthday today!
I love the new song around, but you debuted.
I wanted to thank you for all the joy you've given
throughout my life.
Quiet, Kevin, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Minky cute text.
No text, no text.
Minto, I still have my original PS2 saves of MGS2 and 3
saves.
the memory card.
Also, my saves were twin saves on GameCube.
Wait, that's so awesome.
I still have my memory card, too.
So, I'm surprised it still works.
Yuri, happy birthday, but please stop spamming.
Oh my gosh.
Stop.
I'm gonna have to time you out because you're spamming.
Prepare for the stampede.
No stampede.
Is there a limit per person?
Oh, one.
One, one, one.
I'm not gonna have one, one, one
one Spam Yummy Well, shall we Get to the game, though I'm
excited for off-kite, but I'm also very nervous I mean,
obviously, Den Setu Anu Legends Anu Legends Anu Is in Two
days I might throw up tonight and tomorrow 10 unique teas
then a merch drop later for the pluck my chungus afterlife
but not pluck freak freak my plunge it plug it wait plungus
pluck my no freak my plungus freak my chungus afterlife
limit 10 per person easy easy easy if I have time if I have
time you know obviously they open on Friday if I have time
Saturday I will do 10 more for Sunday how about that I'll
say I'll say somebody at Setonago give me 10 more shirts
I'll see how long the 10 the first 10 take me and then I can
do I'm gonna freak my friend
I keep pressing it up.
Freak
my...
I keep messing it up!
What?
Freak my plongus afterlife!
Gosh.
It has to be that.
Mr. Chichelichel.
Thank you so much for that family gift and wait.
Why are there so many server chats?
I can't keep up, you guys, and it's lagging my computer.
Freak my plongus.
No!
Now you need to make one that says, Freak My Plungus.
No, it's Freak My Chungus Afterlife.
Max, happy birthday!
Happy birthday!
Hold on, let me write Freak My Chungus Afterlife.
Mm-hmm.
freak my... Wait, what's this?
I ordered something, and I'm wondering if they're... If
they're... If they're canceling my order.
I ordered something earlier.
But it's, like, from a Japanese store, and sometimes they're
like, Um, no, we don't like you.
Thank you for your order.
Oh, okay.
It's regarding... Regarding the delivery time.
Okay, okay.
We're good.
No plungus.
Plungus, I mean, my plungus.
Freak it, but I mean, I mean my plungus.
What was I saying?
Wait.
Oh, you guys, I got another email today about my Japanese
visa for living over there.
The attorney, she was like, hello.
Minto phantom.
It has been a very long time since I last reached out.
I recently went to the office to see the status of your
visa, and it is still under review.
I was told that it would take one to three months for a visa
to be processed, and it has been over three months.
I cannot do anything else.
I'm sorry for waiting for you having to wait.
I'm being denied from the country I think What an update I
know right I got the update I got the email and I was like
oh my gosh Wait did it finally go through Nope There is
nothing we can do Yeah she literally was just like I can't
do anymore All we can do is wait Update There is no update I
think I'm stuck where I am But that's okay That's a okay Can
dead people get visas I have to I have to have a visa to
haunt another place Like you know Okay It's kind of
difficult Because like Okay you know a ghost dies They are
Tied to the place that they die But if I'm like a ghost and
I'm like Yeah but I want to go haunt this place I got it
It's like there's there's laws there's rules and regulations
like it's so it's it's it's not so easy freak your plungus
afterlife am i right no chongus japan be like we got enough
ghosts already man right
ghosts are territorial yes yes i didn't die at my pc i died
in my main cafe which i'm always at except when i'm not but
i can't just like go around haunting willy-nilly haunting
permanently willy-nilly yeah i gotta get a haunting license
i'm telling you guys have no regrets when you die okay
because because then you have to go through the afterlife
bureaucracy galaxy bud welcome to membership or welcome back
thank you have no regerts yeah no regerts and and just move
on don't become a ghost it's so overrated this is a game i
adore to no end i hope you have a good time playing home
safety hotline our eyes rest upon me thank you i'm excited
to play
They cannot already have an Akiba specific yokai.
Yeah, there's three of them.
Hey, maid.
If you have enough, if you have time to haunt, you have time
to clean.
Who?
Who are you?
You sound like the spam emails I get.
I know what I'm receiving.
I know when something's not a real offer.
I mean, obviously, the emails are going to be like really
poorly.
formatted and written and everything but they'll be like
hello maid we would like to work with you on promoting Red
Bull and I'm like oh oh you were so close hello maid it's
really easy way to filter them out though
I remember you mentioning that somewhere before yeah
greetings maid I gotta fix my chair
What'd you say?
Avoiding regrets?
Regrets is why I'm heading to two of your concerts this
year.
While it regrets are temporary.
I mean...
Good evening, Miss Channel, big fan of Mirikata.
I mean sorry, Miss...
Miss Chat.
Chat.
Hello, May.
This is my 11th Membushhip.
Thank you very much.
Membush.
thinking it over maybe the delay is because of your criminal
record you are criminally cute
i took a mental damage from that
first name made second name cho cho cho cho cho cho cho cho
cho cho
cho cho chuga chuga chuga choo choo
choo if you had your own energy drink what flavor would you
want it to be also hi i'm it love the new outfit so adorable
on you Erica!
Sorry, emails with greeting cute maid.
Um, if I had an energy drink it would be...
Oh, a melon.
Like a melon cream soda.
Or?
Raspberry.
No.
Melon.
Not mint flavored.
I don't know, mint flavored drink.
Like mint ice cream?
Perfection.
Like mint?
Well, candies?
Mint chocolate candies?
Amazing.
Mint soda?
Or mint, I guess a mint drink?
I don't know.
I mean, there is mint tea.
You lost me at cream?
Like melon cream soda?
Wait, you're missing out on peak.
If you've never had a melon cream soda, I can't even have
soda.
And you are missing out on peak.
Mojitos.
Oh, I've never had one.
I guess you're right.
Yeah, mint tea is good.
I don't know.
Maybe I was an energy drink, though.
Nohitos are cream.
Non-alcoholic mojito.
I want to try.
Oh, I mean, thanks for making membership so low.
Of course, of course.
Thank you for joining.
Thanks for sticking around for two months.
I had peppermint tea while visiting my grandma and it was
delicious.
It's so good, no?
Have you tried mint melon soda?
It's really refreshing.
I've never.
There's a fly in my room.
What?
Okay, I'm going to play the game, though.
I'm going to play the game.
game brandon welcome to membership thank you home safety
hotline you guys i'm excited i'm excited i'm excited i i was
gonna say a little bit about what it's about but i honestly
know so little so oh is that loud
that's like human dna wait hold on i have to figure out how
to adjust sound Uh, one second.
Sorry.
Wait.
Can you do that again?
Why isn't it changing for you guys?
Oh, okay.
I have to change it for you guys, though.
One second.
We'll do like this.
That should be good.
Okay.
Sorry for all the window sounds.
high windows sorry for all the window sounds let me try
again okay that's a bit better okay i'm awake i'm awake i'm
sorry i'm sorry let's let's see how it works okay is that
that might be better let's let's check um our our mailbox
first i'm guest 36.
It's 1996.
Nine months down.
Only 9,999 years and three months ago.
Yippee!
Reset weekly progress.
Oh, this must be the...
Okay, the Discord.
Oh, there's credits.
Oh, how cute!
Okay, hold on.
It's a little loud, I still think.
Sorry, you're going to hear Windows again.
I'm so sorry.
I have to turn it down for me and for you guys, so it's like
double.
Maybe?
Let me know if it sounds better.
Okay, let's see.
TV commercial.
Every year, thousands of families suffer injuries or even
death from common household hazards.
Hazards such as house fires.
Flooding.
Black mold
Metamorphosis Don't become a statistic Call the home safety
hotline and keep your family safe That's me That's me 555
home safety I'll keep you safe Not the black mold That's
traumatizing Wait I wonder if I can turn down the sound in
here That is That is Is that right?
It is full screen.
That's a...
Hmm.
Music volume.
Here we go.
Sound effects volume maybe.
I don't really like the sound of the clicking.
Fear...
Oh, I thought that said fear of birds.
Not fear of being watched.
Wait, what is fear of birds?
has that she's like terrified of geese and stuff fear of
bird watching yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah scopopophobia triple phobia nyctophobia and
entomophobia arachnophobia claustrophobia xenophobia where
does that come from though for dogs
it's me oh subject line welcome if you're a person called
ornithophobia oh that makes sense that makes sense right
from canis oh maybe oh that makes sense that makes sense
canine yeah no slash phobia we're not going haggophobia
minto phobia nobody ever said that right welcome to the home
safety hotline family we are pleased to have you aboard as
our brand new home safety hotline responder slash role your
supervisor's name is carol regina she will be calling you
today to brief you on your duties and will be reviewing your
work daily to ensure maximum accuracy as a reminder
responders with a 90 accuracy rate or more So I am sleepy.
I woke up with like a gnarly headache this morning and it
only just went away like like two hours ago.
A 90% accuracy rate or more will qualify to receive our
daily employee coupons.
Work hard and be rewarded with incredible savings.
Sincerely, HSH, corporate.
Subject line notice video files on desktop.
attention call team due to an error with our archival
network some of you may notice video files oh my gosh this
bug appearing on your desktops videos from wait video files
from our video archive
I'm gonna smush it pretty cool please disregard these they
will be cleared up in due time sincerely HSH corporate
sleepy egg well who's the egg Wait, I'm going to get a
tissue.
I'm going to smush the bug.
Hold on.
Let's smush it.
Wait, where'd it go?
Oh, hold on.
Wait, I've got to smush this bug.
I've got to smash.
Oh, wait.
Where'd it go?
That's a dust.
Where'd the bug go?
Anyway.
Easy.
Video files from our video archive appearing on your
desktops.
Please disregard these.
They will be cleared up in due time.
Sincerely HSH corporate.
So I have to have a 90% accuracy where it's my training art,
my training video and arc and everything.
She's such a killer.
Yeah, I enjoy all the killing.
Monday!
No!
Home safety hotline.
Welcome employee to begin shift, please clock in.
I'm clocking in.
I'm locking in.
I'm clocked in.
Unlocked in.
Bed bugs!
Please.
Ah, wait, we got an audio sample.
shocking scenes tonight as vtuber made mint phantom squishes
defenseless bug voritan i have a call somebody's calling me
hello welcome to home safety hotline new oh it's carol my
name is carol and i'll be acting as your super sh thank you
before you begin your first day here
responder yeah as such it is your job to learn about various
house Hi Carol.
You can answer the questions of our callers intelligently.
Okay.
When I'm- Okay.
Hello, Minto.
I'm at a Muse rock concert right now.
Have fun.
Don't be watching me.
Glad to see you play this game.
I always love people- seeing people play it.
I hope you enjoy HSH.
Thank you, Pencil Tim.
But you should be watching the concert.
Black mold.
Do we have an audio sample?
What if it's just like...
...
Carpenter rants.
Ew.
John.
John here.
It sounds like she's
something in the kitchen.
Speaks of dirt in the kitchen.
Just looks like coffee to me.
I don't know.
Do you drink coffee?
Okay, put on hold.
Please hold.
Wait, I just said that too.
Hi, Minto.
It was funny yesterday with your SpongeBob anchor arms next
to Doki.
Thank you.
All right, black specks now.
It could be cockroaches.
Oh, I'm frozen.
There we go.
Don't cock fear.
Yeah, yeah.
Cockroach infestation droppings that appear similar to
coffee grounds.
I think it's, I think it's, I think it's cockroaches.
Oh, there's so many.
Oh, I think you have a gopher infestation.
that guy do you think they can hear me listening to the
sounds one second I must hear if this is the creature
infesting your home yeah I definitely think it's I don't
think like a carpenter ants wouldn't be like that my small
raccoon jimothy teramites are Ticks.
No, it's definitely got to be cockroaches.
Final answer.
Oh.
Timothy.
Info successfully sent to the client.
Good job.
So they just want to know what they're diagnosed with.
They don't want to know any suggestions on how to fix it.
See that, Zach?
Go for in the coffee.
If you Google Timothy, there's a funny Easter egg.
No way, really?
Hello.
Grace.
Hi, I'm so sorry.
My name is Grace.
Yes.
Probably nothing, but I thought
attic.
Attic.
It sounds kind of
like...
Hold, please.
Please, hold.
Eat, eat, eat in your attic.
Mole?
No, it couldn't be.
Oh, listen.
Look at that guy.
Oh.
Did you guys know there's like a wiki?
of animal sounds and like they have like they class they
like they classify the sound an animal makes and it's so
like you know like hyena is laughter and the American
woodcock is meep like it writes meep and I love the automata
Pia for animal noises.
It's so fun, right?
Me.
You never seen the American woodcock bird?
It, like, it's famous for how it bobs his head.
I can't really do it well.
I think it might be a mouse.
That doesn't...
That doesn't sound like it, though.
Wait, that doesn't sound like a mouse at all.
Maybe I don't know mice.
Thank you.
Last time I had a bug in my room, or a fly in my room, I
opened up the window and said, you don't belong here and it
left.
Actually I had a fly in my room earlier too.
And I did that and it left.
And now I have another bug.
I might have to ask for a new room.
If I get a third fly, I'm out of here.
Check the golfer.
So true.
Golfer in the attic.
but it's a burrow it wouldn't be in the attic right it
wouldn't be in the attic it must be black mold ma'am have
you checked if you have a carbon dioxide leak
i guess it's gotta be a mouse
of squeaking.
It doesn't sound like that, but whatever.
Monoxide.
Wait, what did I say?
Did I say dioxide?
Yeah, monoxide.
Raccoon.
It could be a raccoon.
Wait, it could be a raccoon.
Oh, we don't have a thing.
Raccoons are so sweet.
I love raccoons.
Check the call again.
She went like, ee, ee, ee, which sounds like a typical sound
of a mouse.
But that's not what the sound makes when in the mouse,
mouse, mouse recording.
Miguel!
But I'm a messiah, des, que un des, que un des, love your
new song.
The MV is very nice too.
It's very you.
As a true we would say, totomo kimirashi.
feed I always think of you really that's so funny thank you
Miguel long time no see but I see you commenting so thank
you vtuber in the attic so true only vtubers make a squeaky
sound I'm gonna just say mouse I'm gonna say mouse I got
mouse I got mouse otherwise I would say it's a gopher I'm
lagging again.
Do I lag every time I send the info?
It seems like it, maybe.
Termite.
Icky.
These are all so realistic.
House spider.
Spitter.
House fly.
Oh, it's so...
HSH.
Hank here.
Last week.
I called your guys about some crap in my y
'all brown out there.
Like actual crap?
You better not tell me it's
wrong.
Okay, Hank.
Hank is angry.
Please hold.
It's black mold.
I think it's a gopher.
I think it's gopher time.
Yeah.
Oh, look at this guy.
Tell me how I can get rid of him.
It wouldn't be a raccoon.
Or a mole, yeah, or a mole.
I think gophers are bigger, though, right?
Where'd the mole go?
Yeah.
Living in deep burrows.
Wait, their burrows tend to look like volcano-shaped mounds.
I think it is a mole.
I think it's a mole.
I don't know why I keep freezing.
Sorry, guys.
I think it's a...
I think it's a mole.
Hold on.
I'm going to see if I can fix it.
Wait, someone said check the danger.
Moles are capable of biting humans and spreading deadly
diseases such as rabies, so caution around them is advised.
They also have close relations with the ones beneath the
soils, which can cause further danger if provoked.
I think it's a mole.
Be careful, mister.
You got yourself a mole.
Why do I keep freezing?
Okay, I'm good now.
I don't think it likes when I'm having to choose an answer.
They're tight with the mole men.
Yeah, exactly.
Makes sense to me.
Hmm.
The one's beneath.
And then if it's giant mounds of brown, and then the moles
are making volcano-shaped mounds, make sense to me.
HSH, how can I help you?
Why did it sound like Crunk from Quizco from...
I got pranked, man.
Hey, quit it.
I'm just trying to do my job here.
Oh, Twig Sigmund.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, Tim.
Hey, do you guys have a lawn mowing service or something?
My good for nothing kid refuses to mow and it's getting
rougher here.
What are you doing?
My kid's complaining about being too sick to do anything
about it.
M-m-m-m-m-m.
M-m-m-m.
Stress of this thinking about it.
Can you guys see?
No?
Yeah, why don't you do it?
Wait, I'm actually putting him on a hole.
Wait, what's your issue?
He's sick?
Maybe he has black mold.
Wait, is it time for black mold?
I think he has black mold Your kid is sick From black mold
I didn't think we would ever choose it Yippee Loving your
new song Are you going to post it on Spotify?
And if so, when?
I am going to post it on Spotify But not sure When yet,
Tails Oh You have reached the end of your scheduled work
session for today Please clock out Ah, wait, what did I get
wrong?
Info successfully sent to the client.
Good job.
What did I get wrong?
75%?
I barely passed.
Man, complete the first day.
No coupons.
Human DNA.
What is that part?
Yeah, portraits.
to lasati you don't know me oh mike mike but i used to have
you your job you are needy anger dangire quit today before
it's too late oh don't
It's not too latry to quit freely, to reset me.
Anyway, with the coupons, it's Tuesday.
It's Tuesday.
Should we quit?
He wants his job back, that's what happened.
I took his job, I'm better than, he was getting, I guess 75%
of this guy was getting like 41% terrible.
We got any new entries in here?
None.
La la la la la la la la la la la.
I'm doing a really good job.
La la la la.
I'm working on my computer.
La la la la la la la.
HSS.
This is me too.
How am I?
Oh, it's Carol.
Hello.
It's Carol again, your supervisor.
I'm calling to let you.
Please be aware of the this information is confidential and
not to be shared with anyone outside of HSH.
If you diagnose one of these hazards, we will be providing
only information to the clients that is pertinent to
addressing their concerns.
Nothing more.
Thank you.
We will only be sending information?
Nothing more.
Permissions have been updated.
We got bad!
Uh.
Oh.
Oh, that's the sound of their scratching.
We got bad teeth.
Huh?
Sorry I'm a with
my ventilation or something, because I cannot stop sneezing.
In the past, I haven't had problems so long as I've stayed
inside, but I think something is getting in.
Oh.
Please hold.
What is a bad teeth?
It's a rare kind of household fungus growing in the shapes
of underside bed sheets.
That's disgusting.
Homeowners infested with bad bed.
Oh, it's bed teeth.
Not bad teeth.
I thought they had a case of them and they needed to go to a
dentist.
often report mild discomforts when sleeping such as tickling
or itching but a more rarely slimy acidic residue on their
skin i'm gonna throw up bad teeth are not directly harmful
to most humans given their brief sleeping schedules however
they tend to gradually grow sharper over time which can lead
to infections in the open wound horrible oh wait there is
all carbon monoxide wait how's the sound
freaky cellar growth
large species of fungi that are known to grow in dark damp
environments such as cellars homeowners invested with cellar
growths commonly report a slimy residue the sound of
dripping or stretching and strange glows coming from inside
their cellar what's a common hub what are you I
don't think I like that guy I don't think I like that guy
they're known for their tendency to consume dust dirt and
common sticky substances oh he cleans the stuff wait it's
kind of awesome that's cob oh I kind of like him
false beet false
beets are harmless unless eaten by a human at which point
they will take the root in the human stomach feeding off of
its nutrients for its lifetime they can cause digestive
issues and potential back problems over the course of the
human's life.
I...
Okay, I'm trying to see if there's anything that could cause
sneezing, but...
Uh...
Slimey residue for the stair slug.
I don't know, every time I go through these, I start
freezing.
Sorry, guys.
Pipe hubs.
Oh, I see him in there.
I see him in there.
there freaky pipe growth yeah type of fungus that are known
for making homes inside deep damp tube like structures such
as pipes they will clog the pipe indefinitely till their
removal pipe growth pipe growths are known to make loud
bubbling digestion noises after they eat a full meal you uh
does black mold cause sneezing i
don't think it's bed teeth wait what's uh oh so gross no
they need to have rashes what about bats
bees maybe for pollen oh you think so because he said yeah
we cannot stop sneezing in the past i haven't had problems
so long as i stayed inside but I think something is getting
in.
I think that's what he means, though.
Something is getting in.
Maybe it is bees, then.
Hold on.
Wait.
Where are they under?
Bees.
Homeowners infested with bees, sometimes before it goes in.
Stings or frequent bees' sightings.
Read black mold again?
Common household fungus.
It appears frequently as black spots.
Homeowners with black mold infestations frequently report a
musty smell.
household integrity making it.
It's also known allergic reactions or breathing problems.
Yeah, there's been no buzzings, he said.
Just the pollen.
Allergies?
Wait.
Read the third line.
Yeah, allergic reactions.
Whoa, allergic!
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the...
Were you people couldn't get a ticket to your meeting or a
concert for Off-Kai, but I'm looking forward to hoping,
catching the Densetsu panel on Sunday.
Wait, but also there will also be a Densetsu meet and greet
and my own meet and greet on Friday!
RJ!
Thank you!
I'll try the black mold, but yeah.
Thank you so much, thank you so much!
I guess the grass kid wasn't black mold.
Maybe not.
I hope I can see you!
It's carbon monoxide.
He said something's wrong with the ventilation.
Wait, hold on.
I don't think carbon monoxide would make you sneeze.
Yeah, it causes headaches, dizziness, lethargy.
Like, carbon monoxide is like...
It won't make you, like, have hallucinations and strange...
Strange...
Strange behavior.
Yeah.
I'm gonna say the black mold, then.
Okay.
That guy was on hold forever.
Am I going to be...
Am I going to be frozen forever?
Oh, man.
I'll just get rid of myself if I keep losing...
Oh, Tim again.
Wait.
Hey, yeah, your back rings.
Oh, this guy was the wrong one.
Our stomach's...
Wait, sick to our stomach's and itchy is...
Oops.
I think I messed up that guy.
My bad.
oops they're all itchy but all i told you was to treat some
black mold that's lime disease wait you think he had lime
disease from getting ticks from from mowing oh no i'm to be
fair he was like so vague he didn't even say what his kid
had you know
do you know if there's such a like do you want answers for
ones you get wrong later yeah that'd be fun it's a hob it's
a hob it's a hob it's a hob it's a hob it's a hob it's a hob
it's a hob it's a hob it's a hob it's a hob it's a hob it's
hob hob hob hob hob hob it's a hob it's a hob it's a hob
it's a hob yes yes Hunnigan you have a hob you have a you
have maybe a common hob.
She's got a common hob.
Took that clean, maybe?
To disguise the robbery at night?
I keep coming.
Hearing all this noise coming from my living room.
It's a common hob.
Yes.
Check the other hobbs.
What is that in our living room?
All we had is common hob.
We have desk hob, which it wouldn't be that.
We have pipe hob.
hob and that's it.
I already checked the other hobbs.
Oh, I didn't check a fracture hob.
But this guy probably doesn't clean.
Yeah, he causes cracks and fractures.
The common hob cleans.
We checked that one.
I want a hob too.
Yo, Buzz Goober here.
Buzz Goober.
This guy sounds like cronkies.
again.
Buzz Goober.
I wish the subtitles were a little faster.
Oh.
Never mind.
I wonder if I can fix the subtitles.
Let's see.
Text speed maybe.
There is none.
So sad.
Oh.
Were we gone?
We're back?
I'm gonna... I think I'm gonna...
I'm gonna just not use my myself today.
Sorry, guys.
My camera's off today.
Camera's off today.
Sorry.
Being a little temperamental.
Ooh.
I can't sleep at night knowing...
Full ghost mode.
Please hold.
Okay, let's see.
So crawling in the walls, teeth marks on the bed.
I feel like it's some sort of hob.
House five.
maybe I feel house fire is so funny because what did they
know help my house is on fire what do I do oh it seems like
you we might we might be diagnosing you with a house fire
the um let's see they cause cracks and fractures in the
walls they physically similar to Hobbs and Satcher and size
with the exception of generally longer welder hair locks.
No, I don't think it's a fracture hob.
I feel like if it's...
Okay, maybe a bat?
Because they chew on things.
And scratch on things.
Scratching flapping.
Maybe not that.
Something in the walls.
Can you describe what kind of teeth marks you have?
Like, are they teeny tiny?
Are they teeny tiny?
huge what's the other the other hob is uh i forgot hold on
it's a pipe hob um termites it could be
bedposts a mouse could be termites don't make sound though
see yeah that's the part that i was thinking because you
wouldn't be able to hear it in your walls
gnaw marks gnaw marks sounds of squeaking I think a mice is
our carpenter ants even then I don't think carpenter ants
would be leaving oh wait faint rustling coming from their
walls oh I think it's mice though because this does not talk
about the bite marks but with a mouse it talks about the
bite marks and the and the sounds.
She didn't say squeak.
She just said I can't sleep going there.
She says she hears crawling in the walls.
And it does for carpenter ants say a rustling in the walls.
But I think it's a mouse.
I think it's a mice.
I think it's mice.
Yeah, ants say specifically sounds in wall.
Yeah, but we need sounds in wall and teeth marks.
This has non-marks and sounds of squeaking, which could be
in the walls.
I think it's mouse.
Mises.
Yeah, it's a mises.
You got some mises problem, lady.
Harpender ants make noise because they're teeny tiny power
tools.
Wee.
Let's see.
Black mold, probably.
Freed!
Yeah, hey, I'm calling about a noise I've been hearing in my
house lately.
Okay, yeah.
Scratching, gotcha.
What else you got?
We're quiet.
Pests in your walls.
I set out on kinds of traps.
Okay.
Yeah.
I thought one worked for a while, but then I started hearing
it again this week.
Hearing it again.
I thankfully haven't seen any visible damage.
damage okay no droppings okay you got sand you got
scratching sounds please hold
okay i think this is the ants because it's quiet he says
it's real quiet faint rustling yeah now we have the ants now
we have the ants and they don't have droppings it's the ants
oh my gosh no next they're gonna start singing sing a song
it's mold it's always mold you guys are like house with
lupus except mold carpenter ants no damage oh oh i didn't
catch that part oops I'm wrong.
Sabrina Carpenter Ants.
No!
Do you want the house door?
I can take you to the first, second, third floor.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Oh, dang it.
I think it was Sabrina Carpenter Ants.
Yes?
HSH.
How can I help you?
You guys handle security?
Oh, damn.
I need home security installed.
Okay.
Someone's breaking into my house.
Going through all my stuff at night.
Oh my God.
I know it's Bob from accounting.
Bob from accounting.
Someone's been envious of me.
I know what you're doing, Bob.
Going through my papers.
I'm talking to me with your organization skills.
I need your best.
I think we have a desk cob.
Please hold.
I think organization skills gotta be a desk cob.
They like, they regularly like to tidy their homes and will
frequently sort and order materials in the desk.
Easy.
We got a desk cob, everybody.
The desk cob.
Or should we say the desk bob?
I want the Minto DLC that has eaten snacks and earmarked
doujins as symptoms.
What does that mean?
I would not earmark my doujinshi.
I keep them in pristine condition.
Thank you very much.
And 100% accuracy to everybody who doubted.
Oh, it's carpenter ants.
It's not a mouse.
You were wrong.
Yippee!
Oh, my God.
We're going to get our coop on you guys.
Now that guy's definitely going to, like, come at us.
He's going to be, like, undersoil, chick.
He's going to be, like, now you really need to leave.
You're so bad at your job.
I don't need this job.
need to leave you need to get out of here what's this hmm
real estate update oh wow real estate eighty four thousand
dollars for a house one big tool bath okay no do you want to
live here it's so quaint and so nice oh this one is two bed
three bath 104 000 i actually don't know normal housing
prices they seem maybe kind of reasonable wait four bed five
bath this place is haunted by a ghost but it's really not
community alert a civil authority has issued a missing
persons alert for the following counties bush county maple
county parkway county berry county anyway there's a missing
person's alert authority do you want to live on pink robbie
parker male robbie parker approximately four feet tall
peanut avenue yellow shirt round shorts and white
feet tall whoa
they're just they're a bush
Do you want to live on Barry Lane?
This one is a steal or just a little bit of a fixer-upper.
Uh-oh.
Some kids missing.
We got our coupon!
Oh.
It's too latte fro you now.
They gave you access to more info.
For different day, I warned you, if you will end up like me,
join me in this hole.
The Huey haven't found me yet.
It's for safe, Hetria.
Network errors.
Attention call team.
Our network team is migrating to our back-end services over
to a...
Hold on, I'm moving my chair a little bit.
over to a new hosting provider this week so you you may
experience some occasional network errors over the next few
days please be sure you are studying your information
entries carefully while you still have access in case the
network goes down while you're on a phone call with a client
wait that's terrible they turn that guy into a hub you will
still be expected to provide accurate answers to our callers
regardless of the network status wait this is messed up.
Earned an exclusive employee discount.
Congratulations, employee.
Your high accuracy rate has awarded you today's daily
coupon.
Today's daily coupon is for used horseshoe.
Oh.
Our stock of used horseshoes are reliable as they are rusty.
Or are as reliable as they are rusty.
90% percent of our supply are verifiably forged from real
iron supplies run out quickly so stock up oh we get a little
deal on it i think we have network hobs i think so too
here's a code a great deal for sure i'll get it like sure
but it's sure i get it that's fun is it really too late for
me Wednesday
Surely Okay, did we get, oh wait, is Carol gonna call?
Are we gonna get more access to stuff?
I haven't even, I haven't even, I don't even, I haven't even
stair slugged it up.
Or, or, or, or, or, or fracture hub.
Carol, Carol!
is it you yay hello
thank you what do we got now we've got a bogart ew bogarts
are the general term for a metamorphosed hob they are large
hairy no i'm reading humanoids between six to seven feet
tall fairly convincing false faces they are known for
causing household accidents such as flooding fires
electrical outlets.
They frequently observe their targets while they sleep.
You got a bovart!
No, stop it.
Wait, but...
Wait, is it lurking?
Oh, it's almost as big as my dog.
That's not...
It's so big.
It's huge.
It doesn't hiss or growl.
I don't think it's a...
I don't think it could be...
I don't think it could be a stair slug though.
I haven't even looked at the new stuff.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Oh, dog-sized slugs!
Never mind!
Maybe.
Stairwells and basements.
I think it's a...
Wait, no way.
I literally just said we haven't gotten a stair slug.
And now suddenly, we have a stair slug?
I think we got a stair slug!
Wait, I'm going to look at the other things while we have
time.
False artifact.
Seemingly human-designed objects that can manifest suddenly
inside a home.
They're known for making gentle buzzing sounds that can
usually only be heard by very young human children or small
animals.
Homeowners with false artifacts often report out-of-place
objects or missing children or pets.
That's pretty bad.
This is just like a...
Mitcha chameleon person.
That's a...
Not mitcha chameleon.
Prop hunt.
That's a prop hunt person.
False rose bush or large plant-like creatures that most
commonly take on the appearance of a red rose bush.
In place of roots, these creatures have two small humanoid
feet that they used to chase down prey.
Oh my god, look at its feet.
Yeah, what kind of prey?
Homeowners with false rose bushes sometimes report missing
pets or children why are all these things eaten children and
pets a lamp sprite common subspecies of sprite that make
their home inside lamp fixtures known for causing the lamps
they inhabit to flicker or burn hotter sometimes causing a
burning smell okay they're
tasty oh um due to a clerical error the audio sample
provided it's a memory wisp.
They are odorless household oh gosh.
That are known for removing memories from the home and its
homeowners.
Homeowners infested with memory wisp will often report
missing pictures, photo albums, and the inability to
remember the faces of loved ones.
That's a mirror, man.
subspecies of nymphs that are known for stealing the
likeness of homeowners and passerby they are generally small
faceless and voiceless humanoids carrying a large mirror
that they beckon others to look into homeowners afflicted by
mirror nymphs commonly report not being able to recognize
their own face that's creepy yeah memory i boo i'll call it
a memory i boo instead you know
Tea Sprite Stealing your pictures, replacing them with MGS.
Ew, that just looks like a fly in my tea.
Some species of Sprite that are known to feed off tea and
tea leaf residue.
Leaf-like dropping, sounds of fluttering near kitchens.
Poilet hob.
Their false faces have two separate clumps of wispy hair on
each side.
side of their heads like most hobbs they tend to clean their
homes keeping the toilets they inhabit nearly spotless i'm
oh my gosh why would you call and complain that like your
house is clean can i just get a house full of hobbs please
what the heck and they sound so good unicorn fungi whoa rare
horn-shaped fungus that are known to grow on the heads of
furry mammals and household pets they often affect the
animal's disposition causing them to be drawn to the soil
homeowners often report their pets furiously digging around
or inside their home cool interesting okay what did we say
this was oh you have a stair slug stair slug stair slug yeah
what What does it sound like?
Nice.
You got yourself.
David, you got yourself a stair slug.
Goodbye, goodbye, goodbye.
Alright.
Alright, now we're ready.
We know all the information.
I've downloaded it to my brain.
Felix!
The problem with them, Minky.
Read what you have to do for maintenance with Hobbs, usually
leaving something out every night.
Also that missing kid got eaten by the rose bush for sure.
No!
Hey, Peter.
I've been here coming from the bathroom also recently.
I'm not sure what it could mean.
Is it gurgling?
Ah, nasty smell.
Smell.
Nasty smell.
Wait, it might be a growth.
Oh, it's frozen pipes.
I haven't looked at this actually.
actually it's definitely not that i just wanted to hear it
we have the pipe growth and we have the pipe hob
nasty smell let's see does the pipe hob have a smell i don't
i didn't think they would because they clean someone said
don't read what you have to do about the hobbs and stuff
pipe hobbs are not a direct danger to humans but their
physical presence can sometimes cause they are also capable
of mischievous acts and metamorphosis.
Pipe hops cannot be compelled to leave on their own once
nested.
Instead, one should take measures to prevent provoking
metamorphosis by leaving out a clipping of hair near their
homes at night.
Oh, bald!
Okay, so anything else dealing with oh, there's even more
down here!
Oh my gosh, we missed it!
Whistling fungi!
This is a really
I think they should change the name to Heavenly Fungi.
That's beautiful.
She's bald off camera right now.
How did you know I took my wig off?
When I'm off camera, I'm like, oh, whoa.
I'm like, that's hot.
Peters followed their advice.
It's true.
Sprite.
Bataaracan.
Subspecies of Sprite that are known for consuming wine.
They are small, large-eyed winged creatures with translucent
skin.
They have a long proboscis.
Is that like a, like a, like how butterflies have?
Is that what they use to drink?
Homeowners infested with wine sprites commonly report broken
glasses having their wine, their wine having a rotten taste
and smell.
Wood secretions.
Ooh.
Oh, it is?
Okay, yeah.
The bug trunk knows.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wood secretions are a pink viscous liquid substance that can
sometimes form from wood that has been mistreated.
It is known to drip from wooden materials such as furniture
or walls, causing a sticky pooling buildup.
Can be deadly, causing a rapid translation of flesh if
ingested.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
I think he probably has
Carpenter ants No, I think it's gotta be The pipe growth,
but It didn't say anything about a smell, but I imagine
If it's like digesting, it's kind of gross, right?
And it's a weird noise It says faucet, though
You'd guess frozen
Oh wait, strange faucet cells banging and whistling.
Wait, what?
Wait, that's crazy.
Weird noises coming from this faucet.
Huh.
It's a frozen pipe?
That's it.
Okay.
I thought it would be so explainable, you know?
Like, so...
Okay.
Like, I feel like frozen pipes would be like, yeah, you have
frozen pipes.
But it doesn't smell.
It did say it smells.
Strange faucet smell.
Yeah, it says it was smells.
Smell, smell, smell.
Congrats on your new alpha debut.
Thank you.
I wish you guys could see you today.
Sorry.
My cat.
Oh.
Her face.
It's...
Oh.
Oh, it's gone.
Is this the I-boo?
Oh,
she's dead.
Ooh, creepy.
Oh, God.
It's all gone.
Please hold.
I think this is the memory I-boo.
Removing memories from home.
Often report.
Inability.
Remember the faces of loved ones.
Yeah, this is definitely I-boo.
You guys, uh, leave Quaid alone.
Leave him alone, poor old man.
Poor little pranksters.
You feel bad, do you actually?
Do you actually?
Moe, moe, boom, into streaming while I'm at work.
Good luck with the work!
I thought about the mirror one, but I think that only
happens to the person.
Fred pinball.
I have never seen
a troll team.
What?
I quid like my sunglasses.
Drowers here.
Can you call the right department?
I like how he laughs and then hangs up.
Oh, the subtitles are so slow.
Sorry, I meant to say, I meant to finish.
I said something about the mirror nymph what I meant to say
was it only happens to the person affected so not being able
to recognize their own face not other faces yeah that's what
I meant to say Harvey hi
my sheets are really nasty sharp bad teeth bad teeth bad
teeth bad teeth bad teeth oh Oh, God, Harvey, what the hell,
man?
It's for your skin health?
Please, how old?
Bed teeth time.
Oh.
Oh, the network error.
It happened.
I think they gave us an easy one.
What in so weak?
Harvey, please shower.
Please shower, my man.
Oh, it's still network error.
No.
Uh-oh.
Wanda.
Hello?
My problem.
She's so pretty.
The wall in my bedroom doesn't like all have some cracks.
Pink?
Oh.
Maybe it's such.
But he would never do that to the wall.
He knows just how naughty that would be.
Yeah.
I bet he does.
Dude, maybe it's a...
Cracks?
Please hold.
Maybe it's a fracture hob.
Oh, good.
We're back to normal.
hmm cause cracks and fractures in the walls of the home they
inhabit physically small similar to other hobbs and satcher
and size with the exception of generally longer wilder hair
locks they also bear false foes well my bedroom doesn't look
right near the bottom the bottom has some cracks in the
picture it shows like the cracks on the bottom so maybe
whiskers is innocent.
Whiskers is innocent!
No!
Maybe termites add?
Let's see what termites do.
Termites, termites.
Paint peeling small holes, squeaky floorboards.
Should it say the bottom has some cracks or maybe it's
peeling?
Which is it, lady?
I need more.
I need... I need more information!
The peeling, I feel like, is the is the clue here right i
feel like appealing is the clue here
termites really droppings and dust
unfortunately it doesn't say that though in this you know it
doesn't say that they leave it so we we kind of i think uh
it's not that's not a description so we don't have to.
I think peeling is the big clue here.
So I'm going to go with termites.
I think peeling is our clue.
Termites wouldn't be peeling the wallpaper though.
It literally says termite infestation optimum report peeling
paint.
You guys gotta, you can't think so realistically, I think
with this game.
Because the peeling paint is literally right there.
I think you gotta, you gotta, the game doesn't expect you to
import outside knowledge.
Yeah, you gotta follow the games descriptions of everything
yeah but i want to it's so hard not to gary oh what last my
living room wait what was i wrong
oh it's a hobbs
oh i was right i had a hundred percent rightness
right by the way can't use my outside knowledge of hobbs oh
wait really please how old wait oh gosh i wasn't paying
attention i thought it was just a complaint call wait what
are we living room hobbs wait what was that one is that the
common hob hold on does that say to leave out cream for real
you should take measures to prevent provoking metamorphosis
by leaving out a bowl of Good night.
Yeah, I think it metamorphosized.
Oh, no.
It's been a week and now I've been dealing with this racket.
No thanks to you, but now it's starting to leave power
outages.
Is that the bogert?
The bugger?
The bugger.
Yeah, electric outages.
Oh, no.
Gary, you have a bugger.
The bogie.
You got a bogie.
Good luck.
Good luck with that.
Should have left some cream.
Wouldn't have been that difficult.
Time to move.
Oh, 100% accuracy.
I was right about the termites.
I was right.
Yes.
I'm so good at my job.
That guy's going to be so mad.
He's going to send a big old email being like...
Yeah, hot dog.
I don't know why this helpline exists when you could solve
every single one of these problems by wearing a germanium
bracelet.
They're affordable.
And only downside is a little organ damage.
Buy one today.
I'm, I, this is not my, uh, this is not my, sorry, hold on.
My medical advice, I am not a doctor.
Science.
Ooh.
I love mysteries.
Ooh, science mysteries.
The mystery of mice.
Mice.
One of humanity's oldest friends and oldest enemies.
From the black plague to the shelves of our pet stores.
Mice have lived alongside humans for centuries.
I curse you with reincarnation of the original melting
ridge.
Mouse may even be evolving alongside us as well.
This is a mus musculus.
Mus musculus.
Otherwise known as the common house mouse.
House mouse.
And this is mus musculus loquitis.
Mus musculus.
Otherwise known as the smart mouse.
The smart mouse.
A newly discovered species known for its uniquely colored
iris.
More importantly, it's increased intelligence.
Oh my god.
Mice have brains smaller than penis.
He has a triple brain.
And yet, modern science has observed they are capable of
thinking quite intelligently.
And in the case of a smart mouse, perhaps even capable of
communication.
With the help of modern computer technology, today's
scientists have been able to interpret the previously
indecipherable squeaks.
of a smart mouse and have discovered what seems to be hidden
messages within hidden messages okay is it like help me help
me yeah why is he sound distressed though oh oh oh wait that
was right what maybe i'm an animal whisper I think I'm an
animal whisper you guys What the heck that's freaky She
speaks mouse Guys you're talking to minty cheese right now
Minty cheese you're talking to minty cheese right now Of
course I speak mouse Duh Of course I speak a mouse T-Chase.
Wow.
Freaky.
Is that guy going to be sending me some freaky emails again?
No.
Introducing our new office pet.
We're excited to introduce all of you our office pet
whiskers.
Whiskers is loyal friendly and is as serious about pest
control as we are.
Please give whiskers a warm welcome if you see him wander by
your desk.
Note, please refrain from picking up or feeding whiskers.
as he is still getting to know everyone in the office and
has scheduled feeding times sincerely hsh corporate we got a
kitty wait is he hunting the smart mice you think wait a
second wasn't there that lady that wait what did she have
she had termites why did we take she said she loves her cat
mr like her cat whiskers it's a common cat name i'm sure
it's Nothing.
Yeah, she just called in.
But she only had termites.
Hmm.
It's a common name.
I get a daily coupon of silver medallion.
Dang, what a steal.
This medallion is 100% pure silver and comes free with an
iron chain for convenience.
For safety, both in and out of the home, never let the
medallion leave your sight.
supply is limited to one so get it while you can to receive
your discount simply type the following code during your
online checkout pedal to the metal oh desiree thank you so
much for the rain hello everybody i'm playing i'm playing um
i'm playing game for home safety hotline for the first time.
Rest in Glitchways, thank you so much for the vibe.
Gifted, thank you.
We're going to find out today that there are murdered
termites.
Oh no, we thought she had normal termites.
But they were murder termites.
They were human eating termites.
And yes, you have to, thank you.
Dargo, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
She played the game.
I played the game.
We're on Thursday.
Thursday, Thursday, which is tomorrow
I'm enjoying this so far
Carol, Carol Carol, please call me and tell me how good of a
job I'm doing, please Tomorrow is my last day off from work
Last day off
Carol Hello Supervisor Carol here again That's my caro I've
been watching Be closely employee Yeah I'm impressed so far
By your dedication To accuracy Thank you And once again
Updated your permission She really did tell me How a good of
a job I'm doing Yippee Our eyes rest upon me Our eyes rest
upon me We're Wait, where else did we hear that before?
We heard that phrase before.
When she suddenly whips out the thee.
It was something.
Our eyes rest upon thee.
You heard it from a super chat.
Oh, what?
Whoa, what did I just do?
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
was it a super chat oh maybe attic gnome what do you sound
like
oh we got attic gnome we've got a cellar grotto huge large
cave-like networks known to sometimes appear spontaneously
in cellars gosh i hate when i just get a cellar grotto and
it's so oh it smells so bad i think the map is something
wrong with our faucet oh i thought you're gonna say your
base man i've been having the worst connoisseur pains
constantly oh her lungs still hasn't gone away because we
leave fresh homegrown
absinthe oh well what if it's your grown fruits and veggies
what if wait wait i think i know what it is it's the fake
beat it's the beat it's i think i don't think it's his
faucet at all wait hold on let's see what the new stuff oh
floor roots tree-like brown roots that are known to grow
upwards from the floor to wrap themselves around various
objects or humans in their vicinity yeah I think it's
where's that beat the false beat creatures with a beat-like
appearance that are known to trick gardeners into harvesting
and eating them we only have fresh fruit and vegetables but
they will They will cause digestive issues.
I think it's the beat.
False beat.
Yes.
Poop beat.
Maru, thank you so much for the fun.
Get that.
Yeah, I think the faucet was a red hearing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
What else we got in here?
Oh, I forgot to check the other stuff.
Oopsie.
Felicia!
The police told me to call this number, so I...
I hope I got...
I think somebody is stalking me.
What?
I can see their shots
sent somebody or do something about
it.
Please hold.
Wait, some people pointed this out.
A swallowed false beak cannot be removed without killing its
host.
Oh, seven to...
To Timmy.
We just sentenced to death, I think.
Wait.
They're harmless unless eaten.
well I guess you're just gonna have IBS then unless you know
you're just gonna have some IBS then all right so we got
this lady has someone staring at her through the windows
maybe a night gnome hairy creatures known for their tendency
to enter the sleeping quarters of humans to watch them while
they sleep homeowners affected by night gnomes frequently
report sighting of them in in the middle of the night, or
heavy breathing sounds.
Didn't she say she could still hear it breathing?
IBS forever.
Let's look at the other new ones while we have a second.
The Feast.
Feasts are mid to large size piles of various edible food
substances, and frequently including flour, cornmeal, and
various species of fungi.
they are known to appear near eating areas of the home if
left untouched they could provoke more dangerous activity or
else its continued presence can attract other household
pests such as cockroaches or carpenter ants for maximum
assured safety all members of the home should partake in the
feast they're a sign of a hospital presence an asset should
be consumed immediately one-sided to prevent provoking or
offending the gr the gifter But they're edible food.
Free food.
The fey flu.
Eww!
Rare and dangerous disease commonly spread by household fey.
Symptoms of fey flu include headaches, fever, eye
discoloration, seeds taking root in skin pores, and
blooming.
Is rarely fatal but can have long-lasting effects on the
lifetime health of an infected human.
Long-term symptoms commonly include dizziness, fatigue,
monocolored vision, deliriousness, and endless dreams.
There is no cure for fey flu.
However, one can take precautions against it by keeping a
clean, fey-free home.
It's kind of pretty, though.
The Horde.
An invisible odorless collective consciousness that is known
to collect and store large quantities of common household
refuse.
your house tidy.
Laundry gnome.
Thick fiber like fur.
They can fold their bodies into various shapes and often
resemble dirty towels.
Homeowners with laundry gnomes often report loud rattling or
banging sounds coming from their washing machine and missing
socks.
Oh, this guy is the one taking the socks.
It's you.
We didn't read the night Ibu.
They are known to hover outside windows at night while
whispering promises of wealth and good fortune.
Are they real?
Oh,
he's saying the lottery numbers!
They are not dangerous unless listened to.
Refrain from listening to their whispers and following their
directions.
will move on to other homes after a week or so if they are
ignored consistently.
It is advised to drown out their whispers with music or wear
sleeping masks.
Listen to me.
Address me.
They whispered Mint Doko.
Sorry, I'm having computer issues.
If I'm missing from the screen, always assume computer
issues.
Fun fact, in Fae lore, Feast actually smelled like rotten
eggs and looked like poop but you still had to eat it to
avoid offending the fairies or else they'd curse you with
something worse do they also smell like poop though because
like i'll just close my eyes buy the vinto handmade t-shirts
buy all of them now okay let's see portal i love that game
portals are door-shaped openings to an outdoor location
other than the homeowners discovered most commonly in
basements or underground cellars.
Homeowners with portals frequently report cold drafts,
strange dreams, strong desire to enter.
They should be sealed shut.
Hmm.
A seedling.
Small insectoid creatures about the size of an aphid.
They are known for burrowing in outdoor planters or gardens
feeding off the roots of nearby weeds.
99% of gamblers quit before they win.
So true, so true.
Neppers, thank you so much for 24 months, thank you.
Idol Business Regulation Agency.
Hello, Mint Phantom.
Our agency will conduct a mandatory inspection of your maid
cafe to verify compliance with current building codes.
Please also have your permits, licenses, and certifications
ready.
I'll see you at the Oshi Sparkery and greet.
Um, this is a maid cafe, not an idol agency.
or a idle stage.
Please take your business elsewhere.
I don't need my papers.
I've never needed my papers.
How did you find me here?
Oh my gosh, I just moved.
How did you find me?
How?
I didn't tell anybody I was here.
See you at the meet and greet.
Thank you so much for the peek.
All right, what else we got?
Travel, no.
Oh, I forgot to check my suitcase for travel gnome.
Highly invasive, invasive subspecies of gnome.
Known to stow away inside luggage of unsuspecting travelers.
They are found most commonly in highly forested areas.
To affect the household in various ways, they can often
create expansive gardens inside their new homes.
Leaving soil, plants, and common outdoor pests in the house.
their wake.
These gardens, in addition to increasing, introducing a
variety of dangerous pests, can also create foundational
problems in a home that they continue to grow unabated.
So they travel with you and then set up shop.
That's so rude.
What did we say, Felie?
Oh, she has the night gnome because she's hearing him
breathing outside.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Night gnome.
yeah
my suitcase has a small minto and some light sticks oh no
you do have the travel gnome nice I wish I could get some
good sleep it's a good thing these callers need accuracy and
not speed right I think they give you the time they want you
to look at the stuff in between or you know I think so hello
yes i believe ventilation yeah lately we've been hearing
awful banging noises coming from the ceiling and the air
quality seems to have been drastically reduced mold my
daughter hasn't been able to stop coughing please hold
please hold okay i'm starting to forget some of these
ventilation oh the attic gnome that's right
coming from the ceiling.
Air quality has been drastically reduced.
Yeah, I think you guys are right.
I think it's an attic gnome.
I'm gonna double check other stuff though.
See if there's anything else I remember.
Hmm.
Okay, false artifact.
False bait.
Do you think we're ever gonna get a house fire?
Hmm.
Yeah, I think...
I think the ad pick no makes the most sense here.
Yeah, okay.
I wonder if you do this play...
If you do a playthrough where you get all of them, like,
incorrect, you know?
What happens?
Like, do they fire you for being...
Having 0% accuracy?
Okay.
I wonder the carpenter ants with their mini tools.
I guess I'll be done and...
You got gnomed!
Get gnomed!
Nay!
What's wrong with me?
What's wrong with
me?
Uh oh, it's the bush.
The last time I saw him was when I was tucking him into bed
last night.
messy closet
oh please hold calm the he's please hold okay I don't
obviously I don't think it's the bush what was something
else that could take people oh my gosh hold on oh the breeze
got him the breeze uh
let's see
wasn't the false artifact what made a buzzing sound yes yes
yes so maybe he thinks it's bees but it's not there no one
make a gentle buzzing sound by only here by children it's a
false artifact it's a false artifact ma'am is she holding
the kid in the picture that's so sad what's the solution
once a false artifact has been identified removal is as
simple as physically moving the object out of one's home HSA
pest removal services should be called to come and remove
the object should a pet or loved one already been encased
within one can utilize a memory I boo to speed up the
grieving process that's so messed up oh no
you got a hob several pieces of
Are you supposed to give the cheese to the fracture hob?
Yep.
Fracture hobbs cannot be removed once they nest to prevent
further danger.
Measures to prevent metamorphosis should be taken as soon as
possible.
It is advised to leave out a slice of any kind of cheese.
Oh, I know.
Vivi Korn, thank you so much for the vibe, get to him.
I thought the false artifact solution wouldn't be that bad.
It's so bad.
um but yeah there's several large cracks in the walls of the
basement that were not previously disclosed so i don't think
it's metamorphosized yet he's chased to meet you the guy is
not come on at least finish your meal yeah so you got you
got a fracture hub buddy wait what's the solution they
cannot oh yeah that's right there is no solution sorry there
you go what a plungus freak my plungus life I'm with plungus
I'm with chungus freak our lives freak our lives only
appeasement that sucks they leave giant cracks and you can't
do anything what if I wonder if you could befriend him and
then kind to like have like a you know cheese together you
can like chill and cheese smoking
hot yellow and red light all around me except oh orange
drink orange
drink orange drink oh too many mouths to
Pepper, squeeze, ooh, oh, no, no, wait, though, squeeze was
such a beat.
Squeeze, squeeze, squeeze, squeeze, squeeze, squeeze.
I love when Gober Rubber calls.
The beat go off.
It's so lonely when no one's calling me.
La, la, la, la, la, la.
Hello.
What if I, like, exit out?
oh oh what's happening that's a weird town i don't like that
one oh hey
pink i'm really freaked out right now and i'm not what i
have does he have the fae does he have the fae virus please
hold what was it fae flu oh no
i think he's got that the fay flu he's got COVID you've got
COVID 19 you've got COVID 2026 prank calls or shout out the
ones by a real guy named Longmont potion care so he found
out about the game and they gave him a voice role in the DLC
wait that's so funny he got ligma you gotta tell
Holes.
What?
Uh oh.
You probably took off.
Please hold.
Wait, I'm actually not sure about this one.
Holes?
And it also will eat.
It's a house fly.
Uh, let's see.
Oh, I wonder if it's the, wait, um, what was the gnome that,
the travel gnome?
Was it this one?
Does it, I don't think it actually, wait.
Okay, never mind, they don't deal with pets.
Wait, the unicorn fungi, what if the dog is digging the
holes?
Really big termites, yeah.
I think it's this one, and then the dog is like, trying to
dig and that's where it's gone right probably digging
furiously inside their homes yeah broken floorboards okay I
think it's this one I think it's this one unicorn fungi
oh did he say holes in the wall well we'll see we'll see I
don't know what else would cause holes and then also deal
with a gopher maybe would eat the pet I don't know I don't
know it's fine though if I'm wrong we just don't get you
know our coupon I don't think it was portals because that
leads to some place
Well, hello to you too, Jackie.
I'm back from vacation.
Nobody ever says hi.
Four hours later.
Travel gnome.
A bad rug?
Well, did you?
Please hold.
That's our man.
She said it looks like a nursery.
Like, this is the easiest one.
100% travel gnome.
Travel gnome.
T gnome.
it before standard standard uh protocol i will wait for a
new opportunity to travel to a better location oh you spray
pesticides and weed killer to encourage a travel gnome to
relocate one can invite others to stay at their household
and create new opportunities for the travel gnome to you
just give it to somebody else that's messed up larry okay i
don't know what Yeah, can you tell me what it is?
All I know is when I open my basement door, it smells like a
damn sewer and I can hear it making all kinds of...
It sounds like there might be a lot of water down there too.
I think he's got the grotto.
I don't know what it might be doing down there, but I have a
feeling it's causing a whole lot of damage.
Don't believe it's in the next person?
A
lot of water.
I think he's got the basement grotto, cellar grotto.
We haven't had a cellar growth, no.
uh he didn't mention a glow so i don't think it's that what
did he say it smells bad no i think it's this he says it
smells like sewer bad smell higher humidity yeah can be
removed by finding their creator and presenting them with a
gift of gold their creator often reside somewhere within the
grotto subterranean lake for safety bring and snorkeling
equipment on your excursion?
Can I hire somebody from HSH to do that?
No way.
He said he heard running water.
Yeah, because it's a cave-like system.
It has to be done by the homeowner.
That's messed up.
Got a nutty putty cave your way to like...
Yeah, HSH's Grotto Removal Team.
Okay, just kidding.
Anyway, Seller Grotto, I believe, everybody.
If you agree, say I.
I already sent the info, but...
You can just agree with me anyway.
Oh!
Housefly, I don't even see a takeoff.
Yeah!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You said I.
I boo we're too good at this guys we're too good I haven't
heard from that guy though complete your fourth day of the
job hello oh do not come to the oh do not come to the hole
the hole is breached head I I I repeat the hole is breached
and it's i'm sorry it's bratched is not safe here i must
find a new spot it knows i'm here mike are you good how are
you accessing your emails freak his strongest life i guess
scheduling changes employee 036 regarding your schedule this
week due to a shortage of available staff we will need you
to come into work this saturday and Sunday.
Thanks for being a team player.
Rest assured, your additional labors will be recognized.
Sincerely, HSH corporate.
I had plans this weekend.
No plungus, no plungus, no plungus.
Could Mike be a smart mouse?
Oh, wait, you think so?
I mean, look at this hole.
It's pretty small and whatever's looking in I think Mike is
a smart mouse are they going to turn me into a smart mouse
wait that's the cat oh I see it wait yeah that's whiskers oh
my god
oh minke cheese minke cheese Wait, I'm already a smart
mouse.
I'm already a smart mouse squeak.
It's Michael Mouse.
No!
Daily coupon is a tamed river root.
These are getting quite expensive.
Plucked and tamed straight from the waters within the
undersoil.
This river root is as reliable as they come.
Their gentle high frequency cries are guaranteed to keep
your garden safe from all manner of pests and predators.
Just don't forget to keep them well watered and well
monitored.
To receive your discount, simply type the following code.
Root in for you.
It's like the screaming baby root, whatever it's called.
I'm already a smart mouse, guys.
$550 $550 for a mushroom Hey It's, it's, oh yeah, the
mandrake The mandrake, yeah
Carol, Carol, extend my access please I still have so many
things that are inaccessible
The cat, they brought the cat to get Mike That's what we
were saying Hmm
Whisk Oh, here we go.
Finally.
Hello.
I assume they're going to be a supervisor Minto because I'm
really freaking good at this.
Above, below?
Below?
Below the soil?
Mm-hmm.
Animation.
Ew!
A miniature humanoid figure such as dolls, puppets, or
marionettes, that are capable of moving on their own.
Please hold.
I think that's a new thing.
I don't think it's a closet labyrinth.
Whoa.
Distant cries coming from their closet.
Wait, what was this one?
Dreamweaver.
Oh, I was afraid it was going to be a spider.
She needs to roll for initiative.
Large spider-like creatures known to weave dreams into
reality.
They are also known to cause nearby humans to only dream
about everything being covered in webs.
They will only move into a household if no other spiders are
present.
I think I'm safe then.
We got the false flower.
They are known to take root in indoor potted plants
disguising themselves among the flowers.
Homeowners often report hearing faint singing.
They're harmless if left to their own devices.
However, if homeowners attempt to disrupt or remove them,
they will often lash out by spraying a toxic chemical known
to cause blindness or loss of sight.
Is that them the same thing?
Ignore the singing.
Cobold.
Ew.
It's a dog.
Five foot tall humanoid creatures with dog-like like faces.
They burrow into dark rooms or storage closets and make
their home.
Homeowners infested with kobolds will sometimes report
broken floorboards.
Do not ever enter a kobold's domain.
I guess blindness doesn't need to be total.
I guess that's true.
Loss of sight is temporary, I guess.
Maybe.
The rain nymph.
Oh, it says, can you let me in?
Subspecies of nymph that are most active during rainstorms.
They are faint humanoids with glow in their eyes, often
appearing near windows and doors, asking to be let inside.
Okay, maybe the sprig tree is what we're looking at.
Soap sprites.
Scooby-Doo is a cobalt?
Maybe!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, Rub-Roh, Shaggy!
I'm feeling like I need to go into a dark spot.
Don't come in.
Oh, Roh, Shaggy!
If you're gonna give me Scooby snacks, you better leave them
outside.
Do not enter my domain, Shaggy.
Raggy.
Raggy, I desire food, but I do not wish to exit.
Soap spray tartar is the soap species of spray tartar known
for consuming bacteria and harmful microbes.
They frequently occupy bathrooms appearing similar to pink
bars of soap in order to feed off the hands that use them.
They secrete a suds-like substance that is used to digest
their meals.
they're frequently known to spread deadly diseases such as
fey flu to humans who handle them making them a serious
household hazard easy to remove and dispose of by the way of
tongs or by grabbing utensils it can be difficult to
identify them so it is recommended to not keep any bars of
soap in the household to ensure they can be identified and
removed as soon as possible
oh no
organism that take root in a human body they are known to
cause structural damage to a home as they continue to grow
generally reaching their full size in a matter of days they
are known to be caused by the touch of a sprigan that's the
tree was covered in clothes because or cloth because it's
his clothes her sun has been missing black substance sprig
trees are incredibly deadly to those infected and will
result in death once they have reached a certain size anyone
near a sprig tree while it's growing in an indoor location
is also at risk of injury or death from the structural
damage there's no cure for a sprig tree the infected
individual should be quarantined while any others occupying
the household should vacate the premises immediately do not
touch the infected persons or the black substance that leaks
from them under any circumstance begin looking for a new
home and arrange any funeral services needed for the
affected individual
oh no
no wait oh kason i was like wait is the sun's name kason oh
you're talking about kason deadly premonition wait you're so
right it is casein
no yes wait let's look at the other things we got we got
trash gnome and sprig vines is this similar rapidly growing
vines that are known to quickly consume a house and block
off exits often known often a sign that a spriggin has been
provoked not dangerous on their own but and can be cut
through with common gardening tools however their tendency
to block exits can create struggles when needing to exit the
house in a hurry such in the case of floods fires and a
story spriggin in pursuit the sprig vines will continue to
grow so long as the sprig in that made them desires it it is
advised to vacate or re-home as soon as possible my kids did
yeah your sprig vines are so deadly premonition wait the
sprig at this wait that's so deadly premonition that just
looks like a raccoon everything subspecies of known gnome
gnome with thick brownish gray fur frog-like eyes oh wait
are those are those the eyes or the ears and large gaping
mouths known to seek out trash receptacles and burrow inside
them for both food and shelter
rotting eggs large clumps of fur tipped garbage cans loud
crunching jimothy for snuffy she has she's definitely a
trash gnome okay i'm so sorry lady anyway have a nice day
this is so sad we're often sending people to like their
deaths or telling them that they're like their loved ones
have died we just we're just like we just move on well
probably they're like hysterical and sobbing and having the
worst day of their lives but if they are alive can't you
care by shooting the funco pop oh seven kid i don't know we
couldn't save emily we couldn't save her robert hey i called
last week about some noises in my house yeah following the
instructions you sent me me they still seem to be happening
oh no i already told you that every night i'm hearing
clattering noises coming from the kitchen the kitchen in the
morning i usually check the kitchen for any signs of
droppings or whatever it's a trash no Can you please tell me
what's actually?
I can get some sleep.
Huh.
Clattering noises from the kitchen.
But it's spotless.
Hmm.
I don't think we have a kitchen hob, unfortunately.
A pipe hob.
Maybe.
Barra, uh, commonly emerged from their home.
cleaning what did he say?
it's a clattering noises from the kitchen does it sound like
clattering?
no oh wait wait
it could be a pipe hop that was a clatter I'd say that was a
clatter.
And then if it's clean, it's going to be, you know, it's
spotless, yeah.
Don't forget the cleaning.
Yeah, exactly.
Animation, they mentioned clattering.
But I don't think it would then be spotless, right?
Oh, it does say clattering noises at night.
Maybe the clattering is...
Oh, the whole kitchen, though, not just the sink, yeah.
Presence in a household may indicate the interest of other
potentially dangerous parties.
Yeah, we don't have missing stuff, though, right?
I don't think any other hobbs...
Desk hob, common hob.
A common hob is for the living room.
Desk hob is for the desk and organizing.
Fracture hob, we know.
Causes the...
It's definitely not him.
Pipe hob.
Toilet hob.
Definitely not him, though.
Carbon monoxide.
Honestly, I'm surprised none of these have been that so far.
But clattering does make me think it's an animation, and it
does say that they, like, an intended function?
Like, maybe its function is to clean.
But nothing missing or stolen.
Hmm.
Yeah, its function, it would crumble, right?
I'm not sure about this one.
This one's tough.
The cleaning is definitely like the big We're like, I guess
it's not clean, but it's like, it's, they say it's spotless.
This feels like a trick question.
I know, right?
If I'm sure, go house fire or black mold.
So true.
The persistence is a note for animations.
Wait, it is.
Their persistence in a household may indicate, well, yeah.
Oh, no, prison, sorry.
Oh, if it persists for a few more days, it may be assigned a
more dangerous activity.
Huh.
It doesn't say that it's persistent.
I don't think we've had anything that mentions kitchens.
There's so many things, though.
Holy cow.
Termites tea sprite.
What was that?
Tea sprite again?
Oh yeah, the one in your tea.
Obviously, duh.
Soap sprite?
That's the one that acts like a soap, so no.
Oh my god.
important.
A pipe hob.
Can we read common hob again?
Yeah, let's try it.
They're small.
They have no, uh, they are known for their tendency to
consume dust, dirt, and common sticky substance found on
floors and dishes.
They generally only come out at night.
No clattering, though.
No clattering.
It does say dishes, but...
That didn't sound like clattering at all either.
That was like, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
This one's tough.
This was the toughest one.
Because we have clattering here.
And we have cleaning here.
I think, though...
And we do have a clattering sound effect in here, you know?
Like that.
The colors are kind of bad at describing sounds.
I know.
He's like, here's the short story.
No, I need the long story of it, man.
Are we going to lock in PyPob?
They wouldn't give us the sounds if they weren't supposed to
be used as evidence.
You know what I mean?
so that's why i feel like we can we can attribute the
clattering sound to the audio sample i think so so i'm gonna
go with the pipe hub
yeah hopefully if not i think it was an animation otherwise
but there's no reason it would be maybe he says spotless as
in like nothing moved but then there would be missing or
stolen objects and he didn't mention that you know we're
wrong rip that guy for real yes hi from your company yeah
one of your home security installation services why thank
you a week later i'm still getting break-ins as i'm
singing singing be some insane cereal
safe okay is it that plant it's in the greenhouse please
hold what was that the false false flower
doesn't say that they sing only at night hmm what sing wait
also no there was the night the night i boo do you sing no
you whisper audio sample wait does it have one false yeah
there was the mushroom that sang also this is singing kind
of sounds like a cat talking to itself in the hallway well
this is whistling oh wait if you hear whistling fungi
singing in harmony
I don't think it's this.
Hmm.
These are getting tricky, huh?
What was seedling again?
No singing there.
Okay, portal, pipe bomb, pipe growth.
Knight Ibu.
I feel like the night should be a clue too.
The luck didn't work my flight.
Oh my god, I canceled and I need to reschedule.
No, Death Pigeon, I'm so sorry.
I'm sorry.
That sucks.
In the absence of anything else, I lean flower for now.
Me too.
Um.
Hmm.
Oh, floor roots.
No.
False flower, false bait.
Flower fits with the greenhouse part.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking too.
Maybe they only just hear it at night because...
Wait, what was Dreamweaver?
Oh yeah, the web, the webs.
No.
Does the false rose bush sing?
Doesn't look like it.
Hmm.
I think?
I think we go with the flower.
Maybe it's just quiet enough at night to hear it.
Maybe...
Yeah, the rose bush sounds really weird.
I think we'll go with the flower.
I don't know why we would be like, oh yeah, that's a bush.
False flower.
We'll go with the flower.
It just covers too much of the bases.
Greenhouse.
I guess we can ignore the nighttime aspect.
Bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep,
bleep.
Bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep, bleep.
One second, I'm fixing my mic.
Yes, yes, yes.
How can I help you?
Oh, Flipper!
Hey, Flipper here.
I've got two
of God alkanes.
I don't...
Maybe I know what you mean.
You can't even see my face.
You know what I mean.
I mean, I'm looking at these bells right now here.
Who are you?
Who?
How did you get in?
Whoa.
Hey, now easy there.
Wait, what is that?
No, no!
Wait, what was the squeak?
Wait, I feel like we've heard that before.
Wait, we gotta listen to the noises now.
Hold on.
Oh, what?
Was it the smart mouse?
It wasn't the rose bush.
No, that was...
No, no, no.
I think it's the smart mouse.
Oh, I think it's smart mouse.
What if he was a smart mouse?
Oh.
Hello.
Supervisor
Motives.
Oh.
I've seen to it that this false caller should work employee.
Upon thee.
What'd you do with Flipper?
I enjoyed those.
They got him.
They flippin' got him.
Oh gosh.
Oh no.
Weird call.
There's some kind of insect in my house.
Insect.
I think it may have died.
Fly in through the window and I haven't been able to find it
anywhere
throughout the house.
Oh, isn't that the lamp?
thing and get out of my house wasn't that the lamp um please
hold please hold or was it the lamp sprite because it oh
dang it i think it's the lamp sprite it said that it caused
like bad smell like burning smell you know how smart mice
have blue eyes oh
no they got my guy carbon monoxide it will never be carbon
monoxide you have to give it up it will never be lupus it
will never be lupus it will never be lupus
you have to give it up mouse it will never be carbon
monoxide never be carbon monoxide it it took my daughter it
took my daughter she she's gone go down with it i thought it
was my own
eye please hold please hold i would be i would i would i
would crash out is this the uh what was that
roots what was it the i don't think it's the false bush
unless it could be this or it could be the um oh gosh what
was it called not the vines
what was it oh the floor it was right below me
grow slow enough that they serve very little danger to
awaken aware human adults however if not spotted quickly
they are known to strangling hazard for human children and
pets while they sleep it's a maybe it happened to me last
month a roach electrocuted itself and what about wall
sockets eww could see the antennas sticking out and blood
running down the wall wait that's freaky says nothing about
tendrils for the bush I think it's the floor roots I also
don't see them them and this then but it says the roots are
slow yeah take what took her down with it so something
something wrapped itself around her and like went into the
earth or something
let's see what we got here the sprigan we don't have that as
like uh this might be the sprigan here but we don't have it
Down seems implied by the solution there, does it?
Hold on.
Floor roots.
Requires something to wrap around them before they cease
their growth, so it is advised to acquire dolls.
Place the dolls affected in the room and leave the roots
alone for the night.
By the morning, the dolls and roots should be gone, and the
room should be safe to inhabit.
Make any repairs to the floors as needed.
great hello hello the caller noted he saw it yeah yeah must
pull the doll somewhere exactly exactly okay so we have that
and then let's see the vines real quick but it's it he calls
it it's not like a plant right rest English I thank you I
can't see if to thank you I don't think it's the vines
because they just kind of like grow on walls and block
exits.
Leaving for all night tomorrow, it dropped off from the
kitties to their sitter.
Home's house so empty.
No spank!
See you at the show, MVP.
See you there!
He said tendrils, not behind.
Phil, thank you so much!
I don't remember anything else that like Would have tentacle
like things, you know, maybe a gopher.
Who knows?
Look at these so cute in there.
He's so cute.
Does a false artifact do that?
Encased.
I don't think so.
Maybe it took her while she was asleep.
I was thinking that too.
He doesn't specify, so we wouldn't really know.
otherwise we'll do the false route
or floor roots my bad floor roots
yeah i'm pretty sure we already had the false artifact and
considering how many entries there are i don't imagine
they're gonna have repeats so lots of people having some
freaky stuff going on uh don't know what's going on there
freaky oh hello Oh,
the mirror.
The mirror nymph.
Wow, even her face is gone in the thing.
That's cool.
Please hold.
Actually, we know this.
Wait, let's...
Yeah.
Not being able to recognize their own face.
The fact that homeowners can restore their likeness by
catching the mirror nymph and breaking its mirror with an
iron implement.
I think it's a mirror nymph.
I wonder if it's a mirror nymph.
I don't have so much confidence for 100% this time, but
we'll see.
It was what, the AI, no, it's not the AI, the animation.
Why did I say AI?
The animation one or the pipe guy that we were confused
about.
Fairies can't touch iron.
Oh, really?
Hello?
Anybody get a call?
I'm so bored right now.
though thank you still think is the common hob we'll see but
actually we won't know which sucks we're gonna go thank you
do the police do anything oh
okay ramona please oh i wonder if it's the horde
uh the horde
odorless collective consciousness that is known to collect
and store large quantities of common household refuse.
Rotten food, food, use syringes, rusty metal.
Yep.
Called it.
Called it, baby.
Once introduced to a home, the horde will continue to gather
and hoard their treasures indefinitely.
It is advised to sell one's home at the first sign of the
horde's presence to make the relocation process go over more
smoothly.
To prevent the horde from gathering in one's home, it is
advised to keep one's home as tidy as possible.
Ramona sounds like somebody wasn't cleaning up her rubberly.
So maybe you should take the attitude and put it towards
vacuuming some time.
Huh?
Thank you very much.
Anyway.
Kids are messy.
That's true.
But she don't get to get...
She don't need to get sassy with me.
She doesn't need to be sassy with me.
You know?
is here yeah
it's the night i boo are they whispering financial advice
i hate to tell you man but they're they're actually ghosts
they're ghosts floating lights known to hover outside
windows at night he didn't say anything about the wealth and
fortune maybe it's just maybe maybe he can't hear
flashlights bright lights through the window I think it's
got to be night night I boo he sleeps with the earplugs yeah
get down maple that's an enemy good shit We don't give free
financial advice.
Apparently you do.
Maybe.
What's their best financial advice you would give someone?
I'd say always double down.
Always double down.
Hello?
Patty.
Hey, so...
Barrier Gold.
I think I found some kind of door.
Portal?
Uh-oh.
I think we've already lost her.
Wait, what is the solution for this?
Portals should be sealed shut with wooden planks, bricks, or
other common building materials.
The seal should be airtight as to not allow for anything to
come inside the home.
It is advised to utilize HSH's home security services to
ensure portals are sealed safely.
What's the...
Oh, they sound so pleasant.
They can introduce heating problems.
Oh, no, and cause drag.
lady you got valves portal on steam she's gonna get she's
gonna get gladoced or even worse wheat lead oh no doesn't
say what's actually on the other side of the portal yeah it
might like look like nature and niceness but it's not
actually you know this might like
I went into the bathroom in the middle of the night last
night you know yeah something slithering or
but when i turn on the lights
somewhere like it's too
frightening patty was definitely isekide so true they
checked under the soap oh oh oh oh please hold wait what was
that one called the soap sprite oh no you're gonna get the
flu tendrils or tentacles or whatever
he's already showing signs oh no squid or something but like
there are no tendrils but
uh yeah i'm not sure if it's the soap i'm not quite sure
what it could be then carbon monoxide sorry that was me what
are you doing in this guy's bathroom but it looks like it
though kind of it kind of looks like it has little things 6
stream i encounter after waking up from a nightmare again
random gaming not even gonna say anything yeah it definitely
haunted me right go back to sleep cross arc good night
sink hob no no the
tendrils could be the hair oh maybe wait where was it was a
one all right
toilet hob I
went to the bathroom in the middle and I slithering under
the sink but that's where the soap exists the soap sprite
kind of exists like under this under the sinks and stuff
right
or did it not say that I just assumed that I just made that
up nevermind whenever I turn on the lights I think it is.
I think it's the soap sprite.
Yeah, when you turn it, when you see it like this with the
lights off, okay, hold on.
Whatever, who cares?
I don't need this job.
I'm a mouse.
I don't need this.
I don't need this job.
Who cares?
Who cares anymore?
Get out of my, get out of my little squeaking life.
90% accuracy.
Oh, I wish it told us what we got wrong.
Wish it did.
Friday, complete your fifth day of the job.
Huh?
Is this...
Is that new?
You'll get the angry call.
I guess that's true.
American Great Hacks.
Ooh.
Brought to you by the Home Safety Hotline.
that's the lady that went into the portal thunder peak
thunder peak is one of america's most dangerous yet
rewarding hiking locations
and this guide will show you how you can be the best
prepared for one of nature's most beautiful trails i think
it was always there it just got closer Eww!
Supplies.
As with any hiking trail, you'll want to ensure you come
prepared with supplies to help you meet the demand of
physical trials ahead.
Make sure to bring some hiking boots and also make sure to
bring water bottle and make sure to also bring your iron
sword.
Oh, climbing gloves and definitely your iron sword.
If you don't have access to all these materials, be sure to
consult one of the Thunder Peak Park guides before
embarking.
What the heck is iron sword for?
The trail.
This is a long video.
What if I have a diamond sword?
Thunder Peak is a straightforward but steep trail consisting
mostly of switchbacks leading through a natural cave and
finally a short climb up to its pristine peak.
Pace yourself as you progress.
This both conserves energy and helps you appreciate the
scenery around you.
Be
sure to stop and read the information signs litter along the
trail.
When you see red and yellow lines, it means you are in a
high rockfall area.
Travel with caution.
Once you've entered, the quiet zone remains completely
silent.
As you approach the cave entrance, remove your hiking boots.
Enter the cave.
Do not stop.
Is it going to tell me to prepare my iron sword?
Follow the lights.
Do not stray.
Prepare your iron sword.
If you hear the sound, stay still and unsheath your sword.
Become a shape.
Yeah!
Once you exit the cave, put your boots and gloves for the
fire.
Final climb to the peak.
You made it.
Wait, I missed the super chats though.
Hold on, I'll go read them.
Give me a second.
Give me a single second.
One.
Do you have to leave back through?
Yeah, what do you do?
They didn't.
They didn't say after the, after you wouldn't, what did you
do?
Do you do the same when going back through the cave?
I wonder The instructions are unclear And I'm nervous The
instructions are unclear I'm nervous Let's see Meet Murphy,
Tumi, Rice Nat, Ducky say hi Hi!
Wait are you guys all hanging out?
Stop Hello!
Gotta be iron if you're gonna drive off Ferries Are these
Ferries afraid of iron?
This is new information to me I mean, how would I know I'm
not a fairy?
Right?
Cave beast trying to bait more hikers.
Whoa.
Oh.
Hello.
If you're receiving this email, it's because you have been
mailed by this address before.
The employee this address is registered to is no longer
employed here at Home Safety Hotline.
As of April 30th.
Do you know what day it is?
Wait.
No way.
April 30th, the day Jack and Rose met.
This address will be shut down and no longer able to send or
receive emails.
If you need support from HSH, please email us at support at
hsh.mail.
Whiskers got him.
Mike!
My daily coupon is the haggard.
source cruelty free from the perished and treated with our
flower scented formula these are the best quality hag hides
you'll find this month only will even throw in an iron wall
mount free of charge let the whispers keep your bed the safe
haven it should be sleep easier sleep safer they use this
code haggling for deals oh no matara con they got you how
long is this game by the way they said i need to work
saturday and sunday are those the last two days i imagine
maybe i'm just getting sleepy too
haggling for me though two days left i think okay cool i'm
getting eepy sleepy eepy i mean we don't have that many
entries left so i imagine probably the last two the 30th is
tomorrow you can still save mike hark employee hark lend
your ear once more supervisor carroll here again i've
updated thy permission to information carroll continue thy
labor with prepare thy body the soil wait thy time in the
soil arriveth prepare thy body
No.
Um.
Uh.
Hip hip.
No way.
Let's see what we got.
Autumn vines.
We got the bed hag!
Vines are the orange or red leaves that are known to slowly
grow over a house.
Frequently occurring in the fall.
I was going
to say it's a bat but it's the wine it's the wine thing it's
the wine sprite it's the wine sprite that's so funny wait
what's the bed hag ew large humanoid creatures with an
elderly woman-like appearance they are known to dwell
beneath beds hammocks and other suspended sleeping apparatus
Homeowners infested with bed hags will sometimes report
croaking or wheezing sounds, the feeling of a heavy weight
in their chest at night.
I kind of like that though.
That's a wheeze.
Dorcha?
Dorcha is the one who delivers.
I'm the one who knocks homeowners experiencing dorka
commonly report feelings of immense dread and the sensation
of being followed or pursued they may also experience
visions of a great lurking shadow needs her inhaler speaking
of the hip hip hooray good job on the blessing cover you
sounded so ginky and very oh it's me thank you hip hip
hooray hip hooray Yeah, the cover was so cute.
Leprechaun.
That.
Whoa, where's he pot of gold?
And your rainbow, little man.
Do you guys remember that, like, leprechaun live cam that
was playing, like, oh my gosh.
I don't know, like 15 years ago.
It was probably the first ever live cam.
I ever watched and it was like of a room it was it was of a
room that like was decorated to look like it was outside if
I remember correctly like there were fake bushes and there
was like a blue blue tapestry on the back that made it look
like outside I never saw a leprechaun ever
that's so old it was really old and it was like a website
that was like nobody else watched it hold on
I have to see if there's if we leprechaun live cam I feel
like I'm gonna get some scary something from it but
I swear I never I would watch it as a kid so much And I
never saw a leprechaun.
I missed that one.
Is it just me?
It can't just be me.
I don't know.
I feel like I found a video that kind of looks like it, but
it's actually outside.
And I remember it being a fake room.
But it might have actually been an actual area.
I don't remember.
Anyway.
leprechaun okay we've got neighbors doorway neighbors
doorways are door frames like structures that can often
appear in basements or cellars they're known to cause
confusion if stepped through as well as a parallelism wait
is everything we have everything unlocked now wow the puke
oh that's just my mom's dog commonly inhabit homes in the
shape and likeness of a household pet they are known for
their tendency to replace common pets such as dogs or cats
and live in their place to watch homeowners eat and sleep.
Homeowners with pukas frequently report unusual frightening
pet behavior.
No, that's a puka.
Ah, look at this cat I found.
Have you ever gotten freaked out by dogs that look too
human?
That's me all the time.
There are some dogs that look scarily human.
Reanimation, it's a zombie!
Foul smell, soil be a treasure.
Reanimation's pursuit is slow but relentless.
That sucks.
We got the Spriggan!
We got it!
Green humanoids with leaf-like coatings on their body.
I don't see it.
They are seen rarely in households and reside primarily
inside trees.
Troll.
Le troll.
I've seen a spooky photo of a dog.
And then a warlock remnant.
All right.
We'll get to these when we get to them.
I'm going to grab my food real quick.
I'm getting hungry.
One second.
If the phone rings and...
it.
Just answer it.
Just, ouch.
Oh, yeah.
Hey, yeah.
Thanks for about some kitchen noises.
And your people once again sent me that answer.
maybe bet your people better I'll be going for help
elsewhere now we're having power outages who knows what the
thing in our houses got into now it manifested or whatever
oh no I have no idea power outages I mean it was the it was
a it was a thing it turned into a bough bar so I
need to know what to do about this as soon as possible
there's so many hobbs yeah please how old i guess it was the
common hob maybe no is it wood secretion
does say a foul odor oh wait will be interpreted as a sweet
candy smell oh i think it's the wood secretion then Yeah.
Nice.
But we've done the common hub before.
We did that one before.
I don't know.
There's not many repeats in this game.
Hmm.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Yeah, let's breeze through these guys.
Let's breeze through them.
We got this.
I think there's someone watching me outside something is to
get them but in the trees you say i know they're out there
is that the spriggan my
lawn recently or my fruit in public all you uh-oh hoping
you'll be more helpful
uh i think he's got a spriggan please hold please hold let's
see mowed your lawn like no to act violently violently upon
homeowners when provoked however homeowners affected by
report rapid vine growth.
Feeling that the trees are watching them.
Incredibly dangerous to humans when provoked.
Physical contact with one will result in the growth of a
sprig tree.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tree gopher.
Don't eat fruit in public.
That's a first for me.
I'm learning lots of new legends.
We're famed for removing trees, flowers, weeds from your
property.
Do not ever kill, hunt, wildlife within view of your home.
Do not eat any wild fruit or vegetable that may grow on your
property.
Consider making offers of water each night.
Left in a clean dish.
Yeah, you got a spriggin' man.
My bad.
Don't touch it.
This guy needs an iron sword.
The trees be watching you, my friend.
Just don't watch back.
Man, having to...
to work through my lunch break right now
someone call I'm lonely thank you my brother told me to call
this number but I don't know why things have never been
better around here my brother says he doesn't like the way
the leaves move the way they grow around the house like a
warm embrace oh I think it's the autumn brother brother
would you tell my brother that things are good i always
wanted a brother i always wanted a brother please i always
wanted a brother yeah homeowners with autumn vines are often
report feeling dizzy lightheaded or blissful yeah but wait
to remove autumn vines from a household locate where the
initial growth is coming from by inspecting the soil around
the home?
For an extended red parent vine.
Pull this vine out by the roots and burn it.
Prevent autumn vine growth by making regular offerings of
insects or meat substance to the ones beneath the soil.
Who's beneath the soil?
Why are we going into the soil?
I'm just, I don't want this.
Can I stay at my computer and play video games?
please soil hmm it can cause household accidents hi do you
know how I got here I'm please I was told that
my family wait what I don't know what's happened please tell
me how to get back to my family
Please hold.
I don't think it's the memory.
We've already done this one anyway.
It might be the doorway one.
What was it?
Like, neighbor's door or something?
Hold on.
Neighbor's doorway.
Parallelism.
Neighbor's doorway do not cause any direct harm, but if
stepped through the resulting parallelism, it'll often
result in...
and unwanted household activities such as altered behavior
perceived missing memories in the human who comes through to
the other side
it should be carbon monoxide it makes you lose memory is it
actually it never is carbon monoxide it
doesn't say it doesn't say memory neighbor's doorway i think
it's this one I think it's a doorway Yeah, our family would
be affected too Yeah, yeah Tricky to remove without
accidentally putting one's body through them And potentially
triggering the parallel activity It is advised to utilize
HSH's doorway removal services When can they prevent
neighbors doorway from occurring by practicing mindfulness
And not letting one's mind wander Towards wishing for
alternate life paths Yeah, it's the parallelism, yeah Where
will they look like I am?
Cool.
Just casually getting Isekai.
No biggie, right?
Can you imagine?
Just like, yeah, I just went through a door.
It's literally the title of an anime.
I went through a doorway and now I'm in another world.
And my family's not my family.
And I'm confused.
Oh, whoops, I forgot to press okay.
And I'm confused where I am.
I don't know what to do.
my truck everybody what if there's an anime that's like I'm
a truck driver and everyone keeps getting Isakai different
ways so I'm out of a job in the room
and when I look to see what it was at
the dinner table it's quite big too it's the fay feast which
has me worried that whatever
I mean my dog can't even lay down something that big lay
down that's a fay feast if I ever heard one Please, how old?
We don't even need to check.
Sorry, lady.
Bon appetit!
Itadakimasu!
If she insults it, does it get mad?
Like, are you not allowed to say something bad about it?
Um...
Should be consumed immediately upon one-sided.
All members of the home.
Okay, you can probably say something bad about it.
about it maybe hello rub it up thanks for the group hey yeah
same story freaking
hmm please hold do you think it's that yeah the bed hag
kids can't sleep watch scrubbed all the bed sheets as much
as freaking possible every night's the same story a bunch of
itchy kids with nightmares.
Itchy kids.
Oh, small children and humans suffering from breathing
problems such as asthma.
Known to steal breath of their subjects.
Sometimes sleep paralysis.
Yeah, just itchy.
Itchy kids.
Maw tag.
Maybe it's actually bed bugs though.
Wait, it might actually be bed bugs though.
Hitchiness.
But we don't have nightmares.
We've already done bed teeth before, so I don't think it's
going to be a repeat.
Hitchy and nightmares.
Resistance to pesticides.
Is that what it said?
Bed bugs?
Bed bugs have developed a resistance to majority of common
pesticides.
oh my god
oh the nightmares could be from the itching maybe maybe the
nightmares are like a false you know
I'm gonna
I'm gonna say bed bugs it's funny because everything's been
so paranormal I think it's fun to kind of bring it back to
something realistic you know one second guys let's
get another person in all right all right all right feels
like a solid bed bugs are scary bed bugs are legitimately
scare me i think
i don't remember you My daddy's on the phone, right?
Okay, your heater is not working.
Please, how old are you?
What's worse is cleaning your house does nothing.
Bed bugs don't care how clean you are.
I know, I don't even want to think about them.
They literally give me the heebie-jeebies.
It's so horrible.
I have issues.
I know your teeth hurt.
What was the...
What was...
What was the leprechaun?
I should have read these, sorry.
Long-term damage to heaters, furnaces.
Oh, and leprechauns can occasionally cause direct harm to
humans in cases where homeowners have metallic medical
implants such as braces, crowns, or joint replacements.
So maybe the kid has something like that.
Okay, yeah, it's a leprechaun.
You got a leprechaun, my man.
You got a stinking leprechaun.
what do you do what do you do with him leprechauns we'll
move on to other feeding grounds on their own once they've
run out of food but more proactive means of removal requires
physical capture just grab them just grab them if immediate
removal is desired it is recommended to utilize the pest
control services what
is it the troll i tried to scare the kids
off is it actually a troll I didn't get to read that one,
but...
Steel worn materials such as blankets or clothing.
Trolls will frequently... wait.
Homeowners infested with a troll will frequent report
missing clothes.
Trolls are very dangerous to humans when they are startled
thanks to their ability to inflate their bodies to their
full height of 12 feet in a matter of seconds.
Their skin despite its flexibility is incredibly durable and
will smash through the ceilings of most homes when fully
inflated causing property damage and injury to anyone in the
vicinity do not ever approach a troll an active troll will
leave by morning once it has secured its bounty it is
recommended to install repelling fixtures such as uv lights
to prevent future breakings
play the sound is he gonna inflate he's gonna go oh i
think that's him inflating
the whooping cushion sound is him deflating I think it's a
troll it's a troll
yeah you can google troll inflation you guys if you think
these description if you think the description of this is
something that you're facing right now Google troll
inflation right now
why are we singing Oh,
it's a tea.
Tea Sprite.
My hearing isn't what it used to be, after all.
I got you, Shayla.
Now this tea leaves.
Oh, okay, never mind.
It's a tea Sprite.
Trust.
All you have to say is one word.
One word to set me off.
Just say the word tea.
A flower.
I looked up some pictures and wow, this is exactly what I'm
experiencing.
Unless it's the biggest red herring ever.
They wouldn't do that on a network error.
They would give you something pretty obvious, I feel.
Right.
Because there's no way you can memorize every single little
detail of all of these entries.
And we got an alien calling us.
Hi.
but both my husband and I started feeling short.
It's a hag.
I'm worried about having spreading through our house since
our
kids...
Bed hag.
But that didn't really help Martin
later.
Any knee issues?
Oh, the kids haven't had any issues.
Please hold.
Right?
It's gotta be a bed hag.
Bed hag.
Oh no, it's still a network error time.
I think it's a bed hag.
It's not carbon monoxide, you guys.
I'm sorry.
Wait, that's kind of evil, though.
I can't, I can't, I couldn't, I couldn't double check.
I couldn't double check.
You saved her.
So, uh, I've been hearing this weird sound coming from the
walls.
I'm coming from my walls.
Check the VOD.
Yeah, the whistling fungus.
I think it's the whistling fungus, the whistling fruit.
Please hold.
I'm pretty sure it's this.
Yeah, it sounds like it.
I think it's the whistling fungus.
Non-stop.
They're harmonizing.
Oh, no, no, no.
Carla, you gotta get out of there.
You gotta get out of there.
Oh, my God.
They sound beautiful.
What happens, though?
It says don't return for any reason, but, like, what's going
to go?
What's going to happen?
Do you get sprouted?
I didn't realize this game was so long.
Holy cow.
um hello hello can you help me in my house and i can't
figure out where on earth it's coming
acting up lately oh that's a pokey him it smells so terribly
rotten it's not your dog that's your that's uh that's what
was it called pokey pooka it's a pooka does it smell bad
Wait, no!
The discarded bodies of household pets they leave behind can
over time create other pests and...
No!
Puka thrives on attention they receive from frightened
homeowners.
So refrain from screaming or yelling when surprised by them.
Oh, I'm sad now too.
I didn't know that they... I mean...
Oh, man.
Go away, Puka.
You suck.
Puka...
Cooper!
Never mind.
Mew!
Yes!
Yes, Mark!
100% accuracy!
Holy cow, we're cracks, you guys.
He's a mouse!
Oh my god.
Complete your sixth day on the job.
I'm about to get moused, I think.
Guys, I think I'm about... If I'm not a mouse already, I
think I'm about to turn into a mouse.
Entry browser.
oh look at that we can see everything here that's fun but
also wait what oh there we go okay um it was the science
mysteries right about the mice oh there's a hole now oh
you're right is that where we're gonna go into the soil
I want to compare the mouse noises that they had played in
this, you know?
Mice.
One of humanity's oldest friends and oldest enemies.
From the black plague to the shelves of our pet stores, mice
have lived alongside humans for centuries.
And just like humans, mice may even be evolving alongside us
as well.
Honestly, with how many diseases...
Those that they carry?
Musculus, otherwise known as the common house mouse.
And this is Mus Musculus Loquentes.
Mus Musculus Loquentes.
A newly discovered species known for its uniquely colored
iris.
And more importantly, its increased intelligence.
Mice have brains smaller than peanuts.
Mice have brains?
No way.
observed they are capable of thinking intelligently and in
the case of the smart mouse perhaps even capable of
communication with the help of modern computer technology
today's scientists have been able to interpret the
previously indecipherable squeaks of a smart mouse and have
discovered what seems to be hidden messages within let's
take a listen
Yeah, that was definitely him.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
That was definitely him.
Someone said, check the thing on mice now.
The...
Mice are small, worthless rodents commonly found in the
household.
No!
Homeowners with a mice infestation commonly report gnom
marks, and sound of squeaking mice are capable of carrying
any number of diseases so they serve as an indirect danger
to most humans and should be dealt with immediately oh my
gosh uh common removal methods for mice include the use of
pesticides the introduction of a house cat to the household
and various kinds of bait traps these can prove effective
for small populations large mice infestations should be
dealt with using hsh's pest removal service no that's so
mean You can call the leprechaun useless.
I mean worthless.
Employee number 036.
We are happy to report that we are most pleased with your
labors and are currently making all the necessary
preparations for your impending dissension.
Assuming you pass the trial, the soil is fertile.
Keep up the great work and thanks for working through the
weekend.
Sincerely, HSH corporate.
and my glamour stone what in the big b is this whether
you're too tired to concentrate or you don't want to look
your best without the stress our glamour stones are here to
put you at ease with our patented protection protection
protective seal our glamour stones have a 99.9 reliability
rating wham glam thank you
mate oh yeah oh yeah yeah wolf among us glamour stone
glimmerstone
oh uh oh thy trial hath begun oh I have to do we are many we
are above we are followers of our queen what are are we
please hold please hold uh ants carpenter ants i boo no oh
my gosh i'm not gonna pass
oh bees bees bees bees bees bees bees bees bees bees bees oh
bees you're so right think breeze is better pass showcase
thy knowledge the music is awesome though please call i'm
ready i'm ready to go into the dirt i'm ready to bury myself
i'm ready to taste minerals i am not living yet i clatter i
am small i am weak i serve my purpose then i die What am I?
Oh god, what?
I have to solve freaking riddles!
These freaking widdles!
Uh...
Wait, the animation did...
Wait, I served my purpose and then I die!
The animation, the animation, the animation!
Yeah, because of the clatter.
Forge ahead.
I didn't get to... No wonder they gave us the database.
I didn't get to read all of it though.
Uh oh.
Chats got you, Minto?
Yeah, help me out for some of these, maybe.
Hello?
Took you long enough.
I am the beggar.
I am the encroacher of the dry.
I am friend to the water of the sky.
What am I?
Please, how old?
I have no idea.
the rain nymph maybe
I feel like that's the only thing I can I have I think it's
gotta be in rain nymph otherwise I have no idea let's try it
well yeah they do beg to be let in that's so true you're
right press on employee yeah I'm pressing I'm pressing I'm
pressing I'm kind of I'm I don't really I feel like there's
a disconnect between the mice subplot and whatever cult
going on is happening here.
You know what it means?
I kind of feel like two different things are happening.
Binger, binger, harbinger of death.
I am the bringer of pestilence.
I am forever the nuisance.
What am I?
Please, how old?
I think it's a mouse.
I think it's a mice.
binger it's the mouse it's the mouse baby they hate them
they hate mice why though this game hates mice rejoice did i
make it did i pass i'm i'm like six feet under i seek the
domains of those who have too much step within and they lose
their way because I remember that was the labyrinth closet
closet labyrinth which one is it actually I don't know
closet labyrinth because it said that it made itself in like
rich people's homes and stuff so closet labyrinth I don't
know why I always select it here first
expand thy mind whoa we're below the roots
That was that what made them show up?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
The harbinger of death is a housefly.
I always thought mouse fit better.
Oh, but it says I passed, maybe.
So, I don't know.
Oh, well, whatever.
It said, I don't know.
Whatever.
We are companions of the gardens.
We compel those who tread to tread no longer.
What are we?
Companions of the gardens, we compel those who tread to
tread no longer.
I have no idea.
Maybe both are acceptable?
Maybe.
Yeah, they did mention pestilence, no?
I thought it was the spriggin, but...
Oh, seedlings!
The seedlings?
These were like the tiny little guys.
I don't remember what their thing was, right?
I'm trusting you guys, I'm trusting you guys.
An eyeball, I trust!
Let go, thy stilted soul.
Hmm.
Yeah, tough one.
And we have a lot of nature stuff, so it's kind of...
Kind of difficult.
I am the dancer.
I am the bringer of destruction.
I consume the weak and the reckless.
I am the forsaken oil and the careless light.
I have no idea.
I am the clueless.
I am the stupid.
I am the brainless.
I have no idea.
The house fire!
No, you think?
Okay, I think that's awesome.
Wait, I think that's a great answer.
Yeah!
Going to get employee of the month.
descend wait i'm back in the forest now i need to go i need
to get back under i am the seeker i am the one who knocks i
mean delivers what am i please hold the one who delivers the
one the seeker heisenberg heisenberg
What was the Dorcha again?
Wait, what was the Dorcha?
Can you guys remind me?
Classic Dorcha.
Yo, man, this is the perfect medicine for 14 shift fatigue
things.
Oh, wild monkey.
I hope you're getting lots of rest.
Door dash.
I know.
Dorcha is the one who delivers.
What the?
It was the one who delivers.
God damn right.
I don't remember this one at all, honestly.
I don't.
I wish I could see at least a picture of it.
I'm trusting you guys.
I don't remember.
Dorcha is a thing you chatted through instead of reading.
No, I didn't!
No!
It might have been.
Oopsie!
My bad.
You made the Heisenberg joke.
I did.
think that i would have remembered that
you would have thought like i made like a mental connection
with it that's so funny oh hello supervisor carol here carol
we've been watching you closely for all this time you have
been provided
oh okay promotion and progress please stand by uh
Sick.
I'm feeling a little funky.
Did I win?
Is Carol my girlfriend now?
In the...
Okay.
Hello.
Carol.
quick carol whoa whoa whoa my hat so what happened with the
mouse
okay I feel good yay
I'm a junior supervisor they're doing this to me at my job
tomorrow.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa.
Promotion?
Yeah, me.
That's me.
I'm the new supervisor.
Yeah, this and me.
Oh, yeah.
What is going on?
We did it!
We beat the day.
You guys never got anything like this?
Every time I've been promoted, which is always, I've always
gotten this.
That's how I know the song, duh.
Yippee, I'm a junior supervisor!
Yippee!
wow i'm such a good employee i'm such a great employee and
now i'm your boss well guys that was home safety hotline i'm
very curious in like if you do poorly maybe you go with the
mouse ending the mouse route but we will not be doing that
today but this was a really fun game this was a really fun
game gotta love a game that doesn't take itself too
seriously by the way the DLC is 100% worth it as it doubles
the game length wait I didn't even realize there was DLC no
Whisker gets you no I befriend Whiskers we become like a Tom
and Jerry type relationship where we need each other you
know but this was really really fun i hope you guys enjoyed
it too i didn't expect the game to be so long um but i do
have to skedaddle a bit so i can get some work done before
the weekend weekend christmas dlc wait that's awesome but i
really liked this i like this a lot it was a good it almost
felt like a paper's please in that like you know i just
enjoy games where they like give you information and you
have to kind of like compare everything and It's fun.
It's not, like, so obvious, too.
This was cool.
Thank you for the stream, Minto.
Do our go.
Thank you so much for talking.
So, bye.
Listening, help me focus.
And I was able to finish doing my shirt making.
Yay.
What should I do now?
Oh, God.
I have a flight in the morning.
Have a safe flight.
Congratulations on your promotion, Minto.
This game was really cool.
I really like the vibe.
Can't wait to see you this weekend.
See you soon, Kamo.
Sorry that I've been gone.
Or rather, I'm...
Hold on.
Wait, maybe I can...
I'll...
I'll reappear.
Wait.
Hold.
As I say goodbye.
Thanks for the stream.
Flying out to Off-Kai tomorrow.
Can't wait to cheer you on at the concert.
Make sure to visit Iami's booth as well.
See you.
Verily have a safe flight.
If you are flying out for Off-Kai or if you are traveling
for Off-Kai, if you're walking to Off-Kai because you're so
stinking close, I hope everybody has a safe trip and a fun,
fun time.
If I see you there, I'll see you there.
back I'll see you once I'm back or hopefully I will see you
watching the Densetsu oh wait oh the Densetsu um first 3d
live legends and new yippee yippee yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
It was very bizarre.
Ripped to the kids.
Good luck with the shirts.
Thank you.
I hope to see you at the booth, me, and greet and I'll be
cheering for you at the concert.
See you, see you, see you.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I gotta get going.
Thank you so much, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you for the stream.
And I will see you when I see you next.
Bye-bye.
This is my hands waving.
Look how wiggly my cardigan is.
It's so fun.
Bye-bye.
I'm becoming one with the soil.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Vito.
Can't wait for the comments.
Bye-bye.